foreign
[Music]
[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey you guys yep it's wednesday yep yep
yep look at it
that's that's tom's uh kind of like a
contribution to the discussion yeah and
he wants to turn to the side so you can
see his guns nah
that happens
that's like having you turn sideways to
see your titties
no matter what
well not really now because yeah they're
kind of like under the yeah they're kind
of under the thing of the thing the
thing of the thing i'm so articulate
yeah
all right so today's gonna be a pretty
good show it's gonna we're gonna do the
taking [ __ ] stuff
syphilis experiment uh a lesson in
this is assholery
[ __ ] up i mean as far as i mean
on the scale of like human
experimentation [ __ ]
it's
it's pretty bad it's not up there with
like mangala kind of [ __ ] because
it's it's still pretty bad um it's a
japanese one
what the unit 731
yeah we did a show that was probably the
worst one
that yeah that was that was pretty bad i
mean that was even that made even like
the nazis look i'm not gonna say but
that was like even worse than that so
there's some [ __ ] that went down in
croatia back uh in the 30s even even
even sometimes more recently that was
actually worse than than um
nazi death camps much worse sawing
people's heads off with [ __ ]
actual wood saws boiling people alive
and render them into soap and it's just
a lot more personal than uh than than a
death camp a lot more yeah some people
are just the [ __ ] worst yeah just
ethnic ethnic cleansing
dj maniac says so guess who performed
with voltaire on saturday night was it
you okay
[Laughter]
how's he doing i haven't was he's put up
a couple of live streams recently but i
haven't uh had time to listen to them
because they're usually like pretty long
he calls them his uh video newsletter
so it's usually him and his uh fiancee
pookie's just tearing it up she has like
all her toys over there and she's just
like kicking all the little mice and
earlier today she has like those little
mice that elsa sent and she was having a
staring contest with it she had the
mouse down there and she was just like
sitting and she was just like looking at
it looking at it for like a really long
time yeah and then all of a sudden she
went ah
like jumped on it it didn't move or not
that it was just like really funny so uh
so how was it dj maniac did you have a
good time was was he nice was he a
butthole what what's the story
he seems like a nice dude i mean at
least like on his live streams and [ __ ]
his ex-wife was a good friend of mine
yeah he's he seems like a nice guy yeah
and you know and your friend tanya seems
like a nice person so she wouldn't
necessarily go out with somebody that
was a douche hat although well i don't
know i don't know if that's
no
she was something else too
she worked for chanel she was in the
fashion industry and stuff
she she
she was something else she was fun
though she's fun to hang out with just
cray cray she's great great
uh most girls her age at that time that
were cray cray
uh maniac says pulled me up on stage for
the finale for the chorus of uh when
you're evil awesome i like that song uh
says i've known him since 94 we get
along great yeah like i said i don't
know him but he seems like a nice dude
he's been to
uh eyebar before yeah or barbarella it's
snow now yeah i've talked to him yeah
he's been there a couple of times
talking about tanya i think he was there
wasn't he had momentum maury one time uh
yeah i think that was a couple years
back
like a year or two it wasn't that long
ago because i remember doing the poster
because i did the poster for the show he
played in tampa and he played in orlando
we didn't go to the show but i think he
was at the bar after yeah
when he played in orlando so yeah i
didn't talk to him but tom did
but yeah he seems like a nice dude uh
mary connolly says got two jobs one
contract clean
clean clear paint also small salary
attack site well that's good
that's good always good to get jobs
but uh you know what what do we have to
talk about before we get into the actual
topic grandpa's talking about he's
always thought that impalement would be
the worst way to die
there's a lot of bad ways i mean yeah
i've seen i've seen videos of it yeah
getting impaled like a like a um vlad
the impaler situation where they like
stick the thing up your butt and then
you like kind of slide down it slowly
over time that would suck a lot a lot
because that would take a while
yeah that's mostly intimidating others
uh well yeah but tell that to the person
on the pole
you know what i mean there's worse i
always thought just go look at the
mongolian death coffin
and that could take years to kill you
and they just put you in a little box i
think they let you out once a week just
for a few minutes just they could clean
it out because you [ __ ] in the damn box
and the hole is only that big around you
can't get your head out the side of the
box
you can only get like a hand out
and uh
uh i think they give you a blanket
that's all banned now they don't do that
in mongolia anymore but it was pretty
bad they just had had them in those
boxes stacked up
and those prisons
just uh you know
i think you you were lucky to live five
years i think like that but uh pretty
bad
mongolia death coffin
oh yeah might not want to go that one
would get to his
driveway well yeah
after a while you probably wouldn't even
know and honestly i would argue that it
might actually be
i mean them letting you out for a little
while that might make it worse because
then like like you're out and you're
like whoo and then they like nope now
you're going she's shoving back in there
for another month or whatever i think it
was a week
oh it's a week at a time
i don't know man
i kind of feel i mean anybody after a
time some people could probably like
last a while like that but see
destroying the body can be done quickly
so the suffering's over the real
challenge is to destroy the soul and it
takes a long time and it's it's worse
uh i saw a uh
an interview
with a north korean
colonel i think he was a colonel or a
general and it was his job to oversee
one of the north korean prisons camps
and when uh he defected
to south korea he got his hands on
history books because he didn't know the
history of the outside korea
and
they gave him books on uh
uh
the nazi concentration camps
and uh he laughed at him he he thought
that was that that was nothing he said
uh oh yeah you know he goes go into
concentration camp you were dead within
six months maximum he says it was my job
to kill you over a couple decades it
says i made you suffer you know there's
a [ __ ] dude it almost sounds like he
was bragging though which is like really
[ __ ] up to totally suggest that's
pretty [ __ ] up to like find a book and
like read about nazi atrocities
yeah you saw that was weak i've done
like a hundred times worse than that
it's like yeah good for you he was
talking about he's talking about why are
you proud of that he was talking about
they were they gave him a bunch of damn
um chemicals to test they were chemical
weapons that they wanted to test certain
concentrations of it and he'd bring in
north korean families he'd have the
children and everything and he'd put him
in a room and he'd be on the top and hit
the plexiglass top and he'd drop it down
drop the ampoules through through a hole
in the thing and he wear a gas mask and
him and a couple group group of guys
would uh
time how long it took for them all to
die in the order in which they died and
everything and i think he said he did
several dozen whole families like that
just in one day um you know
and just [ __ ] was cold-blooded
and uh
but the south koreans kept him
just kind of like because he defected
they wanted to know everything he knew
about that prison system you know and he
really didn't have a choice they would
have killed him but he was selected for
just being
super sadistic yeah sure yeah [ __ ] he
they used to make
children
murder their parents and [ __ ] as
punishment you know that yeah i've heard
about that
yeah
make uh little kids eat [ __ ] uh cow
[ __ ] and they did they just
they throw them into open sewage pits
and stuff and laugh at them
um just the idea was to maximize the the
pain and the suffering and the people
that were in there
were being punished for something that
an ancestor did because it was a three
generations you know with something your
grandfather did you could still be in
there as his grandson serving his
sentence just insane
insane [ __ ]
um
it was just it's just a way of getting
rid of excess population really you know
if you ask me because they were using
for slave labor they had one whole
prison that was uh some kind of a mine i
don't know if it was an aluminum mine or
a bauxite mite or coal or something and
you got sentenced to into there for for
life
and once you went in you never saw
sunlight again all their flesh has
fallen off from vitamin d deficiency and
you know they're basically fed nothing
but it takes i think 10 to 15 years to
die in there
imagine that
yeah again that would suck a lot yeah
gram there's hammer said when i was a
cop out west on my fourth day i
responded to an execution style homicide
dude was tied up with phone cord nine
millimeter bullet to the face you still
remember the victim's name alvin k
hibbett
[ __ ] up yeah that is [ __ ] up
um yeah it's just kind of like
i don't know the shit's like you know
depressing and everything but also kind
of interesting lion lion x warrior says
you guys are covering some very topics
great stuff keep up the good work well
thank you well like i said it's i'm
really kind of interested i'm into true
crime is probably my favorite thing but
i'm interested in anything that's
mysterious or anything that's like weird
and i really like dark historical [ __ ]
yeah i'm really really interested in all
that kind of stuff actually it doesn't
even have to be that dark i'm just
really interested in
kind of history that you don't really
think about all that much or
you know that's kind of been lost to
some degree i'm really into that kind of
like
little
highways and byways of history that you
wouldn't necessarily like think of that
kind of stuff is really fascinating to
me yeah we want to do a show about uh
the uh the croatians what were they
called the uh utstachi or ustasia or i
forgot what they were called
they were allies to the nazis but they
they they're still around
and uh they did a [ __ ] wild [ __ ]
against the bosnians and then the
bosnians had their own wild
[ __ ] they were called the uh
the chechnics
and they were just basically just ethnic
cleansing and that [ __ ] went on for a
long long time
basically been going on for centuries
and it was just basically catholics
versus
catholics versus muslims
and uh with
and uh they're about the same race
they're both they're both white people
you know
and uh
and then the jews were caught in the
middle of them too that was [ __ ]
bizarre they're like great yeah that's
all they need yeah they would kill them
with saws and there's uh pictures of it
if you uh
google it they put a guy in his in like
stocks you know how they had stocks of
your head in your hands but it was just
a head and they'd hold the guy down
they'd take a big old coarse wood saw
and start hacking from the back to keep
him as live as long as possible before
they got to those damn carotid arteries
and some people they were
locking them in vats that had a it had a
top on it you couldn't get out of the
water
but you could see out they could see you
and they'd
slowly boil you to death and make you
into soap and then they would sell that
soap knowing what it was that sold that
soap to the public
and uh
man
and evidently they're still kind of like
that if you bring up if you go to if you
go to um
um croatia and start kind of uh nazi
guilt in them they'll kill you on the
spot
just the civilians will
no it's
but you know there's a lot of countries
that are like that
you know
oh hey trey uh we got your blank i
ordered the blank shirt that you wanted
so i got the blank shirt today so we're
going to print it yeah i just got today
and uh get it sent out yeah it took like
a it took a day longer than they said it
was going to but i finally got it
so yeah he'll uh he'll print it tomorrow
and we'll get it
sent out thor quest says date need
bosnian chicks
[Laughter]
did you date any bosnian chicks me no
[Laughter]
no i've never been over there
yeah but i mean bosnian chicks like move
to other countries of the world
presumably sometimes
uh lion x warrior says has tom had any
books published
old boy has mad knowledge
no just we just did uh math mountain
poltergeist i told that story yeah which
he just told that he just told it i just
wrote it that happened
and you know a lot of guys like me who
have military backgrounds you know like
look like terrace pops he had some
paranormal [ __ ] happen to him too
uh when he was uh he was stationed at
abu ghraib prison in there in iraq him
and his uh unit and they said that that
place was haunted as [ __ ]
um
there were torture cells and just you'd
walk around that damn
courtyard that they had inside those
walls and it was just you could just
smell the decay
because it was just
[ __ ] thousands and thousands of down
buried bodies bones had come up on the
surface they were just killing people
and burying them right there
said that that place was [ __ ] spooky
bad and then uh
some survivors were to tell the stories
of what was happening they were
torturing them so bad at the end of the
day they'd they had a uh
eye up in the ceiling
and they'd give them a rope that had a
damn clip on the end of it and they'd
throw it throw it in there they had
three guys to a cell
and uh they'd throw them a noose at the
end of the night if somebody wanted to
kill themselves the other ones would
help him heist him up they'd hang him
if he wanted out it was the only way out
and uh some sometimes you know that
two of them would go in a night and the
third one wanted to go and he couldn't
get up there so they'd have to bring
[ __ ] other inmates in there to help
him hang himself
pretty bad
pretty bad
dj maniac says the [ __ ] cookbook tom
only guy i know who puts out a book and
forgets about it oh yeah i forgot about
that yeah he did forget about it
well maybe that's not what he was
talking about though he was talking well
maybe it's because i mean you just
sat and like talked and i recorded you
right yeah and then i
put the book together so like i wrote
all the interstitial stuff and right
[ __ ] like that and he was talking about
a book upon this on
subjects outside you know yeah so no
that so no i haven't read no books like
that yeah
maybe there are so many other good
uh dudes and historians and [ __ ] out
there you know i mean i
i really couldn't add much to what's out
there it's all out there
yeah i mean there's so many books about
everything pretty much conceivable topic
i'm not saying that it's like oh it's
pointless writing a book about anything
but you know what i'm saying right
might be better to like write fiction
because at least you're like making
making up something that didn't exist in
the world before
[Laughter]
i don't know
but it's you know i say that having
written like three true crime books so
you know right
and i and i didn't think that was a
waste of time i then i actually had a
good time writing it and you know people
seem to like it so whatever but um
tammy says tom's just so modest he
doesn't like to brag lol yeah yeah yeah
right
pretty sure that was sarcasm yeah but
i don't have any hubris or anything
no you're not arrogant in the slightest
um
grant there's hammer i could write a
book about the blood and teeth i've seen
but i'd rather not take a walk down
memory lane yeah it's just uh i
understand that i can understand that
yeah
so uh do you have anything else you
would like to talk about before we start
talking about syphilis
[Music]
[Laughter]
no we can start talking about that now
there's plenty of people in there okay
that's good
uh
so let's talk a little bit about
syphilis because i mean i kind of like
knew about it
just you know because everybody kind of
knows what it is but i didn't really
know a lot of the specifics about it so
i watched like a couple documentaries
about that as well and like read a bunch
of [ __ ] about it it's kind of wiped out
by now
uh not really uh not so much yeah you
don't hear about it as much just because
there's a treatment now and you know
usually if you catch it early enough you
don't have any complications so it's
fine uh but you know it's been around
for a long time and the history of it is
kind of interesting too so i kind of
want to get into that but a lot of
people had it in the past a lot of
people died from they did yeah um one of
the craziest things i've ever seen you
guys can google it you can look at it as
a photograph of a person in a damn
hospital of
late 1800s early 1900s that was born
with syphilis the mom had syphilis
you know while she was pregnant and the
baby came out and was born infected with
syphilis
and grew up like that and it just
doesn't even look like a human
yeah that'd be congenital looks just
like damn eddie from iron maiden off
those iron maiden album covers looks
just like that it's [ __ ] frightening
i mean it's a pretty [ __ ] up disease
to be honest with you um you know and
and it had been around for a really long
time before they figured out
how to do anything about it
uh so yeah you can actually like a
mother can actually like uh transfer it
to her child uh through by the womb
obviously now virus will tear that baby
up but uh it's actually not it's a
bacteria it's bacteria
is what causes it um
and it's largely spread through uh
sexually transmitted disease obviously
uh so there's four different stages of
syphilis uh you got your primary your
secondary your latent and your tertiary
tertiary
so what you have at first uh in your
primary stage
you have um
kind of like a little skin ulceration
now this is crazy because i looked up
the thing i was watching a documentary
about it and they said a word that i had
seen in print before but i'd never heard
anybody say it and i was just kind of
like wait is that how you pronounce it
so i like looked it up now see the word
c-h-a-n-c-r-e
i always thought that was pronounced
canker like a canker sore
it's not it's shanker
and i was just like are you [ __ ] me
it's like so for 50 [ __ ] years i've
been thinking that that was pronounced
completely differently than it actually
is see this is what happens when you
read a lot about [ __ ] but you
you so you know all these weird obscure
words but you never heard anybody say
them out loud so it's like for 50 years
i could have sworn that was pronounced
like i don't know but yeah it's actually
shanker i was just like who [ __ ] knew
i didn't know but yeah so you get those
now usually you just get kind of like
one
like i said it's like a skin ulceration
usually about you know a centimeter or
two in diameter uh but sometimes you get
more than one but it's usually presents
as one
um
then it kind of progresses to
secondary
then you get a rash
usually on the palms of your hands and
the soles of your feet
sometimes you get sores in your mouth or
you know around your genital area
then it seems to go into a latent stage
this can actually last for a really long
time which i guess is
why it took like such a long time for it
to get treated or
even recognized uh because you know
sometimes it goes into this year's long
latent period and it doesn't uh progress
any further than that
uh there so you get pretty much no
symptoms during that period but then
when you get to the tertiary stage
you start getting these little soft like
uh growths kind of like not not tumors
but like little gross
and uh then it kind of progresses into
uh heart problems neurological problems
mental illness like various things uh
usually ending in death
now they also call this disease the
great imitator that's not the only
disease that's called that but it's one
of the diseases it's called that
because a lot of the symptoms that
present are similar to lots of other
diseases so again why it took such a
long time for you know anyone to really
like figure out what's going on with it
so if syphilis is not treated uh the
mortality rate at least according to
wikipedia is between 8 and 58
uh the death rate is higher among men
now
like we were saying uh since uh you know
19th 20th century it's been you know
obviously that's uh you don't get as
many people dying from it and the uh
disease itself has become less severe
like the uh the bacteria is not as
strong or whatever as it used to be and
there's a lot more um you know treatment
so you know if you kind of get in there
early
with the treatment uh usually you don't
have any complications later on so it
can be treated usually uh you know
fairly uh
you know fairly well nowadays
now and another thing though is that if
you have syphilis it actually does
increase the rate of hiv transmission
uh because those two things go together
a lot that's very common
and uh so if you actually have syphilis
you
have a tendency to transfer uh you know
uh
transmit hiv
uh two to five times more than somebody
that doesn't have syphilis it's comorbid
with that
now interestingly this is something that
i thought was an interesting fact 2015
cuba became the first country to
eliminate mother to child transmission
of syphilis
so that was a little fact that i found
that i thought was very interesting
so the first recorded outbreak
of syphilis in europe uh obviously this
isn't nobody actually really knows where
the disease came from which you know
that's kind of another thing
uh but the first time that it was
written down or recorded or whatever
that there was an outbreak of it uh
happened around 1494 1495 that was in
naples italy uh during a french invasion
now because uh it was spread by
uh french troops it inevitably got the
name the french disease
because of course it did
uh the term syphilis was not coined
until 1530
by an italian physician named girolamo
fracastoro
no it's not it's
g-i-r-o-l-a-m-o i know what guillermo
looks like that's spelled completely
differently okay and portuguese
no it's girolamo g-i-r-o-l-m
yeah well that's yeah but i'm just
saying that it's not it's not guillermo
i know i know how that's spelled it's
it's not that you didn't
well yeah well you're not even looking
at the notes and you assume
that it's like that i don't know how to
pronounce guillermo i'm like it's not
gay
it's a it's a totally different name
[Laughter]
but yeah
so uh so again so like i said they're
not really sure where this disease uh
where the bacteria ultimately like came
from
so there are two kind of like schools of
thought on this
uh one of them
says that uh that syphilis actually came
to europe from the americas by
christopher columbus and his crew so
that it had been occurring in the new
world and that they brought it back over
when they came back over
or uh that it went the other way around
that it was like actually in europe
first but it just hadn't been identified
because as i mentioned earlier it
presents the symptoms it presents are
similar to lots of other diseases so
it's possible it could have been around
for a really long time without anyone
really identifying it
another fun fact
syphilis is the first new disease to be
discovered after the invention of the
printing press
so uh and again like when it started
spreading because it spread pretty
quickly
um it was like a big deal like everybody
was writing about it so there's all kind
of like you know after uh the first
outbreak in the late 1400s
uh you get like a lot of uh written
information about it because a lot of
people were like talking about it
uh it's also the first disease that was
actually widely recognized as a sexually
transmitted disease and because of that
it was usually used to uh impugn
people's sexual morals because it's like
obviously if you had syphilis then you
were like a dirty [ __ ] that you know was
getting diseases from like sleeping
around
so uh so there was that whole thing they
just they would like cast aspersions on
your morality because you had syphilis
now uh interestingly this was kind of
the first disease too where you
the first time you kind of got
this almost weird like uh
kind of propaganda type nationalistic
type thing where every country was like
calling it
another country disease you know what i
mean so like i said they call it the
french disease the italians called it
that uh
maltese poland germany they called it
french disease
uh in france they called it the italian
disease because of course they didn't
it's common though
no this is the first time that that
happened man this is the first time that
that happened every time jesus came from
somewhere was he from nazareth was he
from bethlehem
where was he [ __ ] from well wherever
he came from last that's where he was
from
that's what they're doing
yeah well you know there was all kind of
well subjected yeah yeah so uh so yeah
in france they called it the italian
disease like i said uh the dutch called
it the spanish disease yeah the russians
called it the polish disease yeah the
turks called it the christian disease
which i thought that was kind of funny
um so these that other people have yeah
they're giving it to us yeah that's yeah
it's it was basically kind of like a
xenophobic like oh those [ __ ]
and it was it spread real quick
and the perception was correct or not
that
sailors from these other countries were
coming to the ports banging the hookers
and then it was like spreading to the
population so probably true well yeah it
might it probably had some truth to it
because that's probably the ships first
usually yeah because those days well
yeah and like i said that's probably why
it spread so quickly too just because of
the trade routes and things like that
now it's freeways freeways bring it to
you
think about it yeah yeah
but i mean back then that was kind of
like the main way that you did trade
with other yeah so obviously
yeah you know it's like because i kind
of feel like the plague kind of spread
like that too which is not so much from
the people but from the rats yeah or
from the fleas
those damn drivers
the drivers are giving it to you
the drivers yeah everybody's got a car
they're driving around spreading it
uh so then later on they kind of called
it the great pox uh to distinguish it
from smallpox uh or
you know venereal plague cupid's disease
things like that because like i said it
was sexually transmitted
now so it goes on like this for a long
time as i said a lot of people got
really uh you know disfigured because of
it a lot of people died uh because but a
lot of kind of famous people back in the
old days had it
uh it's because like i said it was
it's pretty uh you know it it spread
pretty easily and spread pretty quickly
throughout particularly port cities and
stuff like that
so uh in 1905 they actually isolated the
bacterium that caused it so that was a
good thing and then after that uh they
developed the wasserman reaction which
uh enabled them to identify like who had
it just through a simple blood test
um but
even though they had made that much
progress in the early 20th century they
still didn't know
that much about it they didn't know um
much about how it would progress like
the symptoms and things like that
so and as i said because it's uh
symptoms would sometimes present as
other things so obviously some people
that had syphilis were misdiagnosed or
some people that didn't have syphilis
were diagnosed as having syphilis you
know so it was like a big bunch of
different stages to it too well yeah i
was talking about that earlier four
different stages yeah
and like i said it can go late for a
really long time and sometimes it can go
late for like years
it syphilis is a contributing factor to
the damn
holocaust too because uh oh mustache man
had it
he had it he had it in remission and a
lot of the things that he did actually
kind of symptoms of uh syphilis and
remission once you come up with an idea
you can't back up off of it you never
reverse your decisions real hard-headed
kind of lizard-like
um
but uh and then they then they would
treat it with weird [ __ ]
and uh old hitler had one of the
weirdest [ __ ] syphilis doctors you
could find his name is morel
and morel was giving him all kinds of
[ __ ] weird ass drugs main one big
methamphetamine meth
they wake him up with meth and then
they'd knock him out with morphine
so sounds like a party that's what they
did to him
and uh so
and if in in mein kampf he he he talks a
lot saying that the jews were spreading
it
and
pretty much everybody's sure that he had
it so he probably blamed the jews for it
um that sounds like some [ __ ] he would
do yeah and that they were spreading
these disease everywhere
but that was just one of the many
factors but by the time the
holocaust had happened
everybody who knew him all the witnesses
said that by that time he was [ __ ]
crazy he was [ __ ] he was out of his
mouth well clearly yeah and uh
part of it was losing that bad bottle
for style and grad was part of it lost
all those troops and then that syphilis
was [ __ ] him up and morel was keeping
him real [ __ ] high
said uh
he okayed all that [ __ ] he wasn't the
soul solely responsible everybody else
was responsible for it too you can't
just put it all on him okay man cannot
act alone on a [ __ ] project that big
but he uh didn't say no to it
he didn't say no yeah so
but uh no he made
that was part of it which is weird you'd
think that a disease was was one of the
factors
just it said this was well it just goes
to show how there's all these kind of
like things are way more complicated
everything is very accomplished
especially when you talk about history
because there are like so many factors
that
you know major and minor ones that kind
of like you know all contribute yeah it
contributes to the
to the zeitgeist of the era and things
are mind-altering and and
diseases are mind-altering
in many ways
just look at how they affect society and
then all the drugs that people take to
try to
save themselves from the effects of
these diseases
maria says the murderer john list his
wife had tertiary syphilis i didn't know
that actually
you know i thought we did a show about
him i've been meaning to but
i wanted to do a show about family
annihilators i know we talked about that
um i did one show about it like a long
time we did one show about a long time
ago but i think there was a lot that i
left out because there's like an
alarmingly large number of those
which you know that's special
uh but yeah
so um
so basically what
you know at the beginning of the 20th
century like early 20th century they're
like okay well um obviously we need more
information about this disease how it
manifests you know how long does it take
for symptoms to
uh show up it's like you know what are
the long-term effects of somebody that
has this
um
now so what they wanted to do um
prior to
them uh finding out that penicillin
would treat it
um
they would give people
uh things that would treat it like
arsenic based stuff
mercury based stuff
which um if you're playing along at home
are toxic yeah so what they wanted to
establish they're like look we know that
these are poisons essentially
is it worth it to give these people this
stuff
um
you know to treat syphilis like is
syphilis worse
than
the toxic treatments they're not
obviously they're not giving you like
[ __ ] bowls full of mercury but they
were like i think mercury they were
mostly doing like topical yeah they were
painted on there like a powder yeah
something like that in bismuth they use
that as well and uh some other things
were arsenic based so they knew that
they were toxic but they're basically
wanted to know
you know is it worth it giving them a
little bit of poison to prevent like
much worse [ __ ] later on
yeah
yeah it's basically so they were trying
to like wrestle with that because they
didn't have you know a better treatment
at the time and they're like you know if
this is really sucky then yeah it's
worth it for like a little bit like you
said like chemo
so that was kind of what they wanted to
establish
now the only long-term study of syphilis
that had been done uh was done in oslo
norway
now this had actually been done on
people that that already had syphilis
you know what i mean so it wasn't like
um
you know it was people that had had it
and were being treated for it
and so they kind of went through like
the past case histories for the people
and they had been undergoing the
treatment and they wanted to see like
what the long-term effects of that were
now
uh you know probably this is kind of one
of the things that you know led to the
tuskegee thing uh the study in norway
not surprisingly was all white dudes
so
what ended up happening the early 1930s
come along
and the u.s public health service or phs
if you prefer
uh they were interested in uh starting a
program that would
kind of curb the spread of venereal
disease in the rural south uh because it
was rather endemic in that area
so there was this uh philanthropic
philanthropic philanthropic organization
called the julius rosenwald fund and uh
their whole aim was they wanted to
promote the welfare of african americans
and they were and because as i said
particularly in the south uh syphilis
was widespread in the black community so
they wanted to fund a study to see what
could be done about to like help them
and they also wanted to um
kind of train both white doctors and
black doctors to
you know to help out people that had it
so they gave enough money for two years
of a study
so the study took place in megan county
alabama
now this particular county in the early
1930s 82 percent of the residents were
african-american uh almost all of them
were very very poor uh sharecroppers a
lot of them are sharecroppers a lot of
them were illiterate
and many of them had never seen a doctor
uh they just didn't go couldn't afford
it couldn't there weren't really any
doctors in that area was a very
underserved area as far as medical
treatment went so a lot of them just had
never gone
so they wanted to see uh this this this
first two years this wasn't the the
nefarious [ __ ] here this was just like
the first two years of it and uh they
were just wanting to find out how
widespread it was what they could do to
like train doctors get doctors into the
area to help people that had it and
stuff like that
so what they uh found out
uh
when they did the results and the
testing and everything was that 36
of the african-american population of
macon county had syphilis
now this was much much higher than the
national rate yeah um and at this point
they had done the study and i guess they
you know did kind of what they were
gonna do but then they were kind of
alarmed because they said well
we i think the thing is we because it
was um you know uh an organization that
was trying to like promote the welfare
of black people they were like well the
results of this might suggest because
there was a lot of the [ __ ] going on at
the time that oh well this community is
degenerate morally degenerate and that's
why the rates of syphilis are higher so
we don't really want
that they're having sex
yeah well it's just kind of like well
like i said syphilis was kind of like
seen as like a moral failing because
it's like obviously you were sleeping
around
or sleeping with prostitutes or whatever
it was and so they didn't want to
contribute to further
uh you know kind of marginalizing the
black community which there was already
like a lot of racism about that so they
were just kind of like we don't really
want to continue that then because
people might
interpret that data
in a [ __ ] up kind of way which i'm
sure they would have but so they're like
okay well we funded two years of the
study so we don't really want to do it
anymore
so they didn't want to support the
follow-up project
now uh
because it's kind of like
again at the time there was this is the
early 1930s so there was a perception
that maybe um
the disease was
maybe it was easier for black people to
catch it or maybe they manifested in a
different way and this was something
that was like kind of uh of interest to
certain portions of the medical
community at the time
um so in 1932
the public health service decided
that they were going to do
that they were going to fund a follow-up
study in macon county
now
they weren't really going for the same
uh end goal though
their whole thing
even from the outset they didn't care
about training doctors or nothing like
that
they said what we want to do is find out
what the progression of untreated
syphilis looks like
specifically in african-american males
because as i said
the former study of it had been done on
all white dudes and there was this
perception that the disease maybe
uh you know manifest itself differently
in blacks or maybe see how this is gonna
go yeah
so uh guys that have syphilis and they
don't treat them they just watch them
well yeah like i said even from the
beginning that's what they're they
basically said we want to see like what
untreated syphilis looks like in this
population yeah and i guess which is
crazy when you think about it it is i
understand that [ __ ] these guys are
scientists and [ __ ] but that's just like
yeah we want to see how cancer
progresses we want to see how
yeah it's more [ __ ] up [ __ ] it's like
that dudes like the [ __ ] them
[ __ ] putting them
fly larvae on the dogs just to see how
how long it [ __ ] takes for a fly
larva to eat a dog's face off you know i
mean it's just [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
well the thing is it's like why do you
need to know that
i mean
well the thing about it it's like
they're making money well the thing
about it is that
in this case in the tusky study case i'm
you know i would argue that maybe there
is some medical benefit however small to
knowing the progression of a disease
okay that's not crazy
i'm just saying that the way they went
about it
was really messed up yeah think about it
really most people that have diseases
you're just going to watch it grow well
it's
it's a little more complicated than that
but yeah
let's see how it affects them
you know uh grampa's hammer asks
question for tom what std was the most
prevalent among the gis in korea spread
from the bar girls
none
no i didn't hear about any problems
really no they were all they were all
licensed and like and okayed by the
medics and everything see that's why it
should be legalized i'm just saying
outside of cypher outside the clubs
they'd have this damn safer for the
clients and safer for the safer for the
women as well yep not
and uh legalization
yeah they um
outside the clubs on on the right side
of the door when you walked in there's a
damn plaque there it was a white plaque
with dab
blue eagle on it
like a colonel's rank would look like
and it had a date underneath there and
that was the last time those inspectors
went through there
okay
and uh it was always fresh
that day
and uh no nobody had any problems
but you have to understand that those
girls did not do business with the
public they only did business with the
us army
and we were constantly being
inspected yeah i mean well yeah i mean
it's in the us armies i mean it behooves
them to make sure that they're you know
that their
dudes are not riddled with diseases so
you get inspections on both ends
so uh it was i would say it was safer
than just picking up a random girl at
the damn bar
i imagined it probably was
yeah because that girl you don't know
who that pokemon
is you don't know where she's been yeah
you don't know same with the dude you
don't know where he's been either
you know where those girls pretty much
been yeah they've been with the dudes
you live with yeah you know and they're
all just like you that's why there's so
much uniformity in the army but that's
back when the army was [ __ ]
functional
and you know back in the 80s in the
ninth the 90s late 80s early 90s the
army was awesome up until the last this
[ __ ] that second part of the
gulf war man it just slowly just chewed
the army apart it never really recovered
yeah it's not the same army today
i laugh at it
now terrace pop said he had a guest on a
couple days ago guy who's active in
there right now what he's describing is
just describing a nightmare there's no
incentive to join that army do not join
any of these armed forces that's my
especially not the army there's no
incentive
it's they're going to end up being
drafty armies eventually
you won't get anything out of going
there
and they'll treat you like a criminal
when you come out so there's no sense of
going
grantham's hammer says when i went to
several months of training in brunswick
georgia they told us not to smush with
any locals because hiv and herpes were
so prevalent
interesting
korea was a paradise in those days it
was an army of young men fresh from the
united states doing their job and an
army of young korean women there to
entertain them and it was just looking
high quality on both heads everybody was
having fun maria says tom it was
chlamydia for the army in the 1980s
probably
that's not a big problem
yeah i kind of feel like most of those
types of you know gonorrhea [ __ ] like
that never caught any [ __ ] like you know
it's not i'm sure it's not fun to get so
i wouldn't know but it's not like fun to
get but um you know most of them can be
treated that's minor
yeah it's pretty minor it's mostly just
like a [ __ ] nuisance more than
anything yeah i mean it's still not
something you want to get obviously but
you know
the clap
yeah i remember my grandpa talking about
that
because he was he was uh yeah he was in
the artist was he in the army or the i
think he thought he was
i can't remember if he was army or
marines that was a long time ago i never
heard anybody getting crabs
yeah it's like i i heard more people
like joking about it than people
actually having it i'm sure people have
had it obviously it's a thing yeah but
i never knew anybody that had it or that
would admit
you know the old story go you're going
commando that's true we didn't wear any
underwear in the field you don't
rarely wore it even in garrison
and uh most uh infantry and [ __ ]
recon types and [ __ ] like that are well
groomed you can't really you don't want
any potty hair really because it's just
just
filthy you know what i mean looking you
don't give me much toilet paper
and you're out in the wild you know
[ __ ] trying to survive and trying to
keep clean you just don't want any hair
you didn't really want any hair on your
head
so
yeah
i so
you're not going to be attacked by crabs
you don't have anywhere to hide you know
the crabs are anywhere to hide
a little patty crab
maria says chlamydia is dangerous for
women very few symptoms but can lead to
pelvic inflammatory disease and
infertility yeah i had heard that
actually so um okay so where was i
yeah so
as i said um even though it seems like
you know the first two years of this
when it was funded by someone else like
a you know a more
philanthropic uh situation
uh after it got taken over they really
didn't make a secret
out of the fact that the whole point of
the study was they wanted to see what
would happen
if syphilis was left untreated
specifically
in black men that's what they wanted
so they actually got and i was like
watching something i was watching like a
you know a black history channel uh
thing about this it was like 15 minutes
long it was actually really good
and um he was saying that he's like you
know there's like some people that don't
really like that it's called the
tuskegee
you know syphilis study or whatever
because like the people of tuskegee
didn't have anything to do with it it
just kind of happened
that they got the teaching hospital
there and that's where they did the
study and you know it's like and it
sucks that like that town name has like
become
not synonymous with the study but
everybody calls it that
so and you know and people are like look
i just lived here i didn't do it you
know what i mean it just happened that
it just happened that they did it at
that particular like uh institute in the
teaching hospital
uh the actual name
of the study
uh was the tuskegee study of untreated
syphilis in the negro male so like i
said they weren't hiding what it was
it was the 1930s y'all
uh so initially
the study was really only supposed to go
on for like six to eight months i think
and i think that initially maybe
uh i think they were actually planning
to treat it
treat the syphilis eventually
uh spoiler alert that's not what
happened uh the study actually ended up
going on for about 40 years
and maybe would have continued if uh
another scientist hadn't blown the
whistle on it so you know went on for 40
years we'll we'll get into that in a bit
okay yeah so
it was initially supposed to yeah well i
don't know that was like a lot of [ __ ]
that was going on okay so as i said it
was supposed to be like shorter
now the initial subject group uh was
616 men
412 of those had syphilis
204 of them did not they were the
controls
now
how the
researchers who are involved in this
thank you
bryce pardo new zealand
always wanted to know more about this
weird experiment yeah
pretty weird it's pretty weird uh danny
rolling ghostface says can't you catch
crabs from a public toilet seat uh you
know what i always heard that but i'm
not actually sure honestly
i'm going with mythbusters and like some
other [ __ ] that i've heard here there's
not a lot that you can actually catch
from a toilet seat because usually
toilet seats are one too slick and two
too cold for a lot of like real bad like
cooties to live on for very long well
i'm just saying that's that's a general
scientific term yes cooties and um
so
they're probably uh toilet seats are
actually probably a lot cleaner than
like the doorknob of the bathroom of the
public bathroom i'm just gonna say that
uh you know i mean i wouldn't lick it or
anything but
i know cause you know how like some
women don't like to use public toilets
and they'll like hover which is gross
but
that's what they have like [ __ ]
toilet seat covers for for christ's sake
but honestly i don't they're damned
they're not as germy as people perceive
them as
they're way less germy than like some
other pieces like i said the [ __ ]
the bathroom doorknob is dirtier the
worst thing in the damn house or
anywhere is the sponge you clean you can
clean uh plates with your sink that's
the worst
yeah because that's just like full of
little nooks and crannies that all kind
of like cooties could be living in try
to explain that to a boomer
yeah see i don't understand like
obviously obviously
that's because you're washing like gross
ass like food and stuff like that off
and then you're not even like really
cleaning it i mean we run ours through
the dishwasher but
it's just kind of like
it's a sponge it has all kind of little
holes and it's damp
and it's that's just a magnet for
[ __ ] bacteria man
toilet seat like i said kind of slick
kind of cold
a lot of cooties don't like that kind of
environment remember my grandmother's
kitchen my mom's kitchen and everything
always hanging things from the damn oven
door [ __ ] handles and little [ __ ]
things and it's their little rags and
then cute little [ __ ] things and you
go that's a filth catcher man you
[ __ ] throw that [ __ ] out you know
but they were just raised to put like
[ __ ] doilies on everything it just
catches filth
you know oh it's to keep it clean no
it's not it just gets it [ __ ] dirty
put a tablecloth that keeps the table
clean no you're just putting something
filthy on top of the damn table [ __ ]
spray the table off
yeah honestly and you know uh i that's
why i kind of i'm glad that like newer
houses nowadays don't have as much
carpet yeah because now our our house
the whole lower floor is tile which is
nice but the whole upper floor and the
stairs have carpet which i would rather
i would actually rather have zero carpet
yep i do not i do not like carpet but
it's the cost it just yeah [ __ ] you
find a house that's like that man in
this [ __ ] 20 30 000. well yeah
because nobody wants carpet anymore
because everybody understands all it
does is catch filth and stink yep and
it's just kind of like so you know you
spill your coffee on it and you're like
oh well [ __ ] there's that's all she
wrote so what i got is i got a good
electrolux vacuum cleaner and a good
electrolux carpet shampooer
yeah which is that's the only defense is
that as good as having a hardwood floor
nope that's just wood and tile
throw rugs easy
yeah
lot better honestly just washable
thrower eggs you can just [ __ ] throw
in the washing machine i don't know i
like a good i like a good you know silk
[ __ ] woven silk oriental rugs you
know it's all nice too you know but
because you can clean those also you can
take them outside beat them [ __ ]
shampoo
it's silk you know yeah nice [ __ ]
but
no
carpeting is a [ __ ] back in the 70s i
thought that [ __ ] was cool man going up
the walls and [ __ ]
[ __ ] well nowadays everybody feels
good it's just yeah that's all it is
yeah and you know especially like i said
if you you know if you have cats or dogs
or whatever it's just kind of like
catching hair and
all kind of crap they have a good vacuum
cleaner yeah
camp guy said i try to add clorox to the
cloths if i'm washing mostly underwear
or whites yeah we usually bleach the
kitchen towels which are white
but yeah i don't have i don't do the
paper towels i buy it at sam's kitchen
towels
get several uses out of this it's a lot
better just like you know it's like a
working in restaurants you learn the
tricks you know paper towels real towels
yeah like i said if you have white ones
you just throw them all in and bleach
them yeah
much cheaper and you get many many uses
out of them and then once they get too
kind of stained up and they look like
[ __ ] you make them garage
rags
you know for working on your car or
whatever camp guy said i've heard you
should microwave your sponge every night
and tammy said yeah i'd do that you
could do that or just throw that [ __ ]
away
yeah i mean like i said we usually buy
them at sam so we buy like big stacks
or like i'll run them through the
dishwasher like we're doing like i'll
just throw them in the dishwasher yeah
you use that to just like clean a pot
and then then half the time if the pot
could fit in the dishwasher i'll put it
in the dishwasher yeah some of my pots
are too big to go in a dishwasher though
i got some of that big around that tall
you could [ __ ] deep fry a turkey and
damn pot that's how big some of my pots
are
man's pot
a whole african tribe would [ __ ]
they'd trade off three brides to get
their hand on that damn pot you could
[ __ ] cook a whole pig in it
i thought you were going to say you
could cook a whole bride in it no
unless she was real small then if you
ever been livi if you ever lived outside
or you [ __ ] from mississippi or any
kind of tribal [ __ ] [ __ ] you have you
have to understand how much of a
lifesaver a gigantic pot is
i can use some gigantic indians [ __ ]
if you look at back in history indians
didn't give a [ __ ] about guns they
wanted pots
well i i imagine that pot well pots are
more useful day to day
it's like you know guns you might use
every now and then but it's like pots we
got to use that like several times a day
like for every meal so
yeah like and probably you were always
like losing them or breaking them or
something like that so you always needed
them it was just something you use like
several times a day so i could see that
a lot more practical yep
okay so where was i all right so the uh
the people who are involved in the study
as i said didn't really make a secret
about what the you know what their end
goal was
but they justified it to themselves and
others
by saying well we're not really hurting
them
because uh even if they had known that
they had you know syphilis they wouldn't
have gone to the doctor anyway
um because they just didn't like in this
community like i said either because
they didn't trust doctors or because
there were no doctors around or because
they couldn't afford it or whatever so
they're basically like well this
community doesn't go to doctors anyways
so it's not like we're doing anything
nefarious because they wouldn't have
gone anyway you know what i mean so
that's kind of what their reasoning was
so as i mentioned earlier
uh
the
overarching belief at the time was that
the effects of syphilis
depended on what race you were like the
people that had it
now interestingly doctors largely
believed
that syphilis
as manifested in
an african-american man
would actually be more like affect their
cardiovascular system more rather than
their central nervous system
this seems to have been
an inherently racist assumption
because they believed at the time
that black people had less developed or
inferior brains
therefore
if they got syphilis
then there was
less brain for it to affect so it
manifested in other ways like in their
heart instead that seems to have been
what they thought so that's special
um i thought they were more simple more
primitive and robust they could take the
damage
yeah that's essentially that's
essentially what they were saying yeah
and it's like and i'm not making that up
either that's like that's the kind of
[ __ ] that they said back then
so yeah so that seems to have been what
they thought well it's probably you'd
[ __ ] compare of trout to a catfish
that's what they're talking about
[Music]
catfish you'd cut a catfish head off
i've done it before and throwing the
head up near the [ __ ] on the on on
either throw it next to the [ __ ]
lake come back the next day and try to
fish again and that catfish head still
sitting there the gills [ __ ] pumping
that's unsettling [ __ ] yeah
and he kicked the head into the water it
was alive still
ah
yeah that's horrible well like thinking
about that because remember how because
i think i've mentioned this before like
on a few shows where it's like i have
this really weird
[ __ ] up fascination with like
beheading yeah and because i'm always
kind of like man if somebody cut your
head off like how long like how long
would you be aware because other people
have been fascinated by this as well
because they did all those like [ __ ]
up studies and stuff when they invented
the guillotine and whatnot and so
the fact that a fish
could stop and i'm not saying that fish
are super aware like in general when
they still have their bodies
but
the fact that you can cut off a fish
head and it's still kind of like sitting
there alive not any fish catfish that
really like makes me i only saw that
with a catfish because how [ __ ]
horrible would that be as a person like
getting your head cut off and you like
were laying there for a couple minutes
going well [ __ ] me
yeah
it's just a catfish i can't imagine like
i never noticed that with any other kind
of fish just catfish just catfish
catfish are [ __ ] super tough
yeah there's like yeah you cut my whole
body off i'm still alive [ __ ]
[Laughter]
the same thing with like i've heard that
you could cut a roach's head off in a
roach and live for weeks that they i've
heard that as well just die of
starvation because they can't eat
[ __ ] typical and uh because their
brain their brain is and the brain part
in the head is pretty basic they have
other little brains going down there not
really a spinal column but it's like a
central cortex that goes down
they have brains and then weird places
you know what i mean next to the legs
and [ __ ]
so there the brain has been divided up
into several places each one do another
thing you know
each little brainlet doing other doing
special tasks
but cutting the head off doesn't kill it
well [ __ ] i've smushed a roach and then
it just look was kind of like okay and
then it just got up and walked off i was
like you [ __ ] that's why i don't
like them i don't trust [ __ ]
cockroaches man
because you can just and i saw a
comedian a long time ago i think it was
paula poundstone and she was talking
about florida and she's talking about
florida bugs which obviously like big
cockroaches
and she's like
she's like you know uh you could drop a
brick on a florida bug and in a second
that brick will start to move and now
the bug has a weapon
and i was like yeah pretty much i
dropped a dictionary on one one time and
it didn't kill it like a bit and i'm
talking about like the big webster's on
a bridge [ __ ] damn one good
thing about this house
we've been here
two months now
and i've only seen a couple of bugs and
it was little bitty
little bitty roach that came in don't
jinx it and that was because we left the
window open
yeah
don't jinx it left the window open now
that you say that we're gonna have like
a [ __ ] invasion you haven't seen any
bugs not he made major bugs
maybe it's because maybe it's because
it's like the yard is kind of open and
there's not like a lot of houses are far
apart and the houses are far apart and
i'm not entirely sure why maybe there's
a lot of bats and
other animals around here that eat them
i don't know it's not densely populated
here yet yeah maybe that's why so that's
not attracting them
yeah grandpa's hammer said in the 1950s
a farmer cut off the head of a chicken
and it lived for weeks he would put
kernels of corn in the neck and he'll
defeat it yeah that he had a name too
didn't he yeah it had a name they were
showing it to people and there's v
there's there's i saw they had a um a
replica of it at the um ripley's museum
in saint augustine i think i got a
picture of it actually part of that
was intact though
yeah chop the head off but it only
took off part of the head the brain stem
was still there
it was just that that it was essentially
unconscious though you know it's
i would hope so it's frontal lobes and
everything were gone it was just like
the brain stem
and it was running around acting like
another chicken and it was
it was
the other chickens were like
it was blind and trying to eat i'm
trying to peck the clip it'd be like a
chicken horror movie holy crap like the
[ __ ]
now that they still chickens nowadays
still tell like the legend of the
headless chicken yeah
it was like a sleepy hollow it was like
a zombie though it's it's behavior
wasn't normal you know
oh yeah
zombie chicken it was a zombie chicken i
mean please tell me somebody's made that
movie i mean we did see the turkey one
that's for sure that's true that was
kind of like a zombie i guess well not
really he was more like i don't know
he was like a demon turkey
uh jason willie says tom and jenny i've
followed you for years and you guys
deserve more subs and attention well
thank you very much thank you very much
we don't want to get too famous now you
know that might just be like two
mike that was the chicken's name that's
right i knew it had like i was like i
wanted to say it was like timmy i was
like no that's not right
but yeah they had a um
when i went to the ripley's believe it
or not museum in st augustine they had
like a little
a little barnyard area that had like all
like the two-headed cow and all that
kind of stuff replicas of it it wasn't
like real ones and it had like mike the
headless chicken and had a little thing
about him on there and i think i took a
picture of it but i don't remember what
happened to it
not a living chicken
or not a living [ __ ] it could be
that's the porn version
or you know it could go either way
please tell me somebody made a horror
movie about mike the headless chicken
that'd be super funny we should make one
uh okay so uh so yeah so
now how do you get people to participate
in this study that you're doing
so what they did was they actually like
recruited a lot of people in the black
community you know pastors nurses things
like that
and they told people
that uh they basically they didn't tell
them it was a study or an experiment or
nothing like that they basically said
this is like a program we're gonna give
you free medical care
um
you know and you can have like various
things but they didn't tell any of the
people that came in
uh they didn't tell the ones that had
syphilis after they did the test they
didn't tell them
um some of them didn't but like i said
that was a control group
uh and they didn't tell them what the
outcome of syphilis could be
which you know if you didn't know mental
illness like i said blindness deafness
heart disease
uh bone deterioration
central nervous system collapse
death just terrible
so what they told the guys and i think
maria brought this up earlier
was that they were being treated for a
condition just colloquially known as
bad blood
and bad blood in that community pretty
much could mean syphilis but it also
meant anemia anemia fatigue pretty much
any
it was like a catch-all term
so they said we're just treating them
for sickness yeah so we're just going to
be treating you for that and it's free
and you know and and all this stuff and
it'll be cool
now
interestingly white folks gonna help you
yeah and well and they recruited like
other people in the black community too
and i don't know because there's one
nurse in particular that they're still
kind of like a controversy about her
because they don't actually know
if she knew what was going on or if they
had like fooled her too
into like getting all these people
because she was like one of the main
people that got because she worked for
the phs but she um
and she was a nurse but she actually got
a lot of the recruits in there
but they don't know
if she and i think she died in the 80s
but um
they don't know if she knew actually
like what the study was or if they just
said hey why don't you go out to the
black community and get them to come in
here for this for this free medical
program that we're doing you know what
i'm saying i probably didn't know i'm
yeah i'm imagining she probably didn't
know but people just have no jobs
they're punching the clock and they just
that's what i'm saying it's really hard
um and so
and this kind of goes back to another
thing that we're with that we always say
about how everything is like more
complicated and everything i know it's
really easy to just blame like one
company or one organization one
you know government agency whatever it
is but the thing about it is that those
are all comprised of like thousands of
people most of those people like you
said are just [ __ ] clock punchers
they don't know what the [ __ ] going on
they just go in there they do their job
they go home to their families just like
everybody else does and so
how responsible can you hold like just
some random ass
you know mid-level bureaucrat somewhere
who probably didn't even know what the
[ __ ] was going on it's like government
some of the government jobs i've been
involved in and [ __ ] government
contractors
the overall [ __ ] mission might sound
super high speed but everything's
compartmentalized and these compartments
filled with people that have no idea
what the [ __ ] going on
and
looking back on it a lot of those jobs
are fake
they're just kind of like jobs programs
and some of the above it's got a big
contract and they go oh i got 70 000
people we got to keep employed and uh
give us 40 million dollars a year we're
gonna be fine we'll take care of it and
it's all just
going out of washington dc you see them
big old buildings and there's not a lot
of action most people are working at
home and
the offices are empty
you can do everything on a laptop now
and that's the way skyscrapers used to
be it's weird when you think about it
but now i'm getting off topic but uh
it's just like in the medical industry
what they're doing chances are
most of the people that were involved in
this didn't really know what they were
doing
and honestly a small thing that they
were it was yeah it was one project
because i will say again spoiler alert
that it was actually somebody from the
same organization
that
blew the whistle on them and they
weren't the only one like people
over the years like other people in that
organization also complain like hey this
is [ __ ] up you might want to look into
that so it's not it was just kind of
like this one little subset of people
yeah that was doing this one study
there's something that you some people
have called a phenomena called
institutional evil where you have an
institution it's huge it's got thousands
of thousands of people in it each one of
them doing next to nothing
but the institution itself is like a set
on a course of
destructive behavior overall and you
can't change it no one person has enough
power to change the institution
uh a lot of that is going on inside
inside all governments
and and corporations too yeah i mean
once you get to a certain like size when
you get to a certain point yeah yeah you
can't really control it you're gonna
have all kind of like different outcomes
that maybe you didn't because like i
said most of the people involved don't
know what's going on like the harley
davidson corporation was a [ __ ]
corporation mostly at war with itself
some of the people wanted to update the
products the other product the other
people inside there were almost like
real hardly religious fanatics they
wanted harley to stay exactly the same
and that [ __ ] company would sit there
and fight with himself and run along for
decades doing the same thing year to
year and year year to year and
up until recently you didn't see any new
harley davidsons now they got some new
[ __ ] coming but a lot of people don't
like it it's just the weird little
institutions are like that
yeah medical institute so it's really
hard to blame and i and i can understand
like you know people's need to like we
want to blame one person or something
like that but it's really hard to do
um particularly in cases like that i
mean i'm not saying that sometimes like
with some corporate malfeasance or
whatever there might have been like a
small cabal in there that absolutely
knew what the [ __ ] was going on and they
should be and they should be held
responsible but i'm just saying don't
hold people that just like [ __ ] work
there in a regular ass job don't hold
them responsible because they probably
didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
unless they did and then you can blame
them as well but they probably don't see
the movie apocalypse now it's a great
example of how
militaries are corporations that are
like that or a modern military is
u.s army went in there it ran on
autopilot it was just an institution of
evil
it didn't get anything done
it made a lot of money for somebody
somewhere the generals made all kinds of
[ __ ] money and had bought houses and
they even had swimming pools
it's just insane
it's insane
large
don't trust large organizations the
bigger it is the more dangerous it is
that's my experience
corporations yeah because like i said a
lot of times once it gets to a certain
size even the people that like are
running it don't even really even know
it's like a monster yeah or it's like
i'm not saying they don't know exactly
what's going on but they might not know
like the whole like ramifications yeah
what the [ __ ] and they can't change
anything anyway
then there's a board of directors and
shareholders and all kinds of [ __ ] and
they can't change anything
so institutional evil also known as
institutional senility
where it's just it's like that now it
won't change you can't change itself
maria points out uh and this is actually
a good point she says this might have
been about social class as much as race
there were educated black people
involved that nurse for instance and
they had their prejudices about poor
people those in the study yeah that's
actually a good point because as i said
they did have
other like leaders in the community that
were trying to like recruit people into
this study
i'm not saying that like the people came
to like the preachers and stuff like
that and said hey we're doing this study
they probably just gave them the same
[ __ ] line that they gave to the
actual people in the studies
but that one woman i think that's why
there's a controversy about that one
woman i can't remember her name but i
haven't written down like later on in my
notes
but um
i think that's why there's still
controversy about her because she did
actually work for the public health
service so she might have known or had
an inkling of what was going on
and so some people are like well they're
not really sure
you know did they just say go out and
like recruit people we're doing this
nice thing for you guys or
did she know what the purpose of the
study was like i said they weren't
making a secret they called the study
what it was so it's not like they were
trying to hide it really but they did
hide it from
from the subjects though we like to we
like to [ __ ] step back and say well
that was the 30s you know they treated
poor people like garbage back then you
know what i mean it wouldn't happen
today now poor people have always been
treated about like garbage people like
garbage today same [ __ ] i mean that's
kind of like one of the things about
being poor is like you just
get treated like garbage excess
population that's kind of like extra
extra extra unneeded people
but yeah so that's what you're seeing
yeah
um
okay so at this point now they did know
even though penicillin hadn't come along
yet because like i said it's still 1932.
but
um all the medical textbooks of the day
um
did say that syphilis should be treated
as soon as possible because the
ramifications of it while they weren't
completely understood they're like are
bad enough
that you know something should be done
about it as soon as possible as i
mentioned before penicillin came along
uh the only things they used as
treatment and they weren't real
effective
they were kind of effective
but not
you know it was it was minimal but it
did something but not that much uh so
most of the stuff that they used was
arsenic based uh called like uh
arsphenamine or sphenamine which is
called the 606 formula
and uh then they had uh mercury like i
said bismuth and uh so those were kind
of effective
you know better than nothing but not
really all that great
so
they did actually give those treatments
uh
by and large to the people in the study
they also gave them
uh
placebos which is pretty standard
practice like especially for the control
group they usually just give you saline
solution or something like that and tell
you it's like medicine so you know so
you have like a
double blind kind of thing everybody's
getting the same treatment but nobody
knows who's actually getting the
treatment or not um
they also but they also gave them like
unnecessary
x-rays unnecessary spinal taps for
christ's sake which are very painful
um just saying yeah this is we're
treating your quote unquote bad blood so
that's what they did so they gave them a
bunch of
unneeded uh medical tests and [ __ ] like
that
and again they didn't tell them they
honestly didn't even tell them that it
was an experiment or a study they
basically said it's a program we're
treating bad blood and that's it they
didn't say you guys are lab rats um
that's even though that's what they were
gonna tell them that because they they
assumed they probably assumed maybe
rightly that they
that one they either would walk away
from the experiment two they wouldn't
you couldn't grasp what an experiment
was that's what they thought probably
they probably did think that honestly
they won't understand what explain i
mean we're treating them for what's
wrong with them yeah they'll understand
that and i do kind of feel like there
was maybe a lot of that going on because
i think they did think
that you know oh all the people in the
study were stupid right or were
illiterate they don't know anything
they'd never been to a doctor before
right you know and so
there was kind of like a little bit of a
thing where we can kind of do what we
want to them because and make no mistake
the people above us are saying and
thinking and doing the same thing to us
behind our back they lie to us too
well like i said yeah they lied to
everybody
they'll just tell us a [ __ ] better
lie
so okay so where was i all right um
yeah so
weirdly they did actually as far as i
could determine i don't know if they
gave it to all of the people that had
syphilis but they did give them
some of the minimally effective kind of
treatments like the arsenic [ __ ] and
everything like that
um so they did do that
but
another thing though was that when
penicillin came along
uh and was shown to be quite effective
in treating
syphilis
they
didn't tell the study participants about
it for one thing and as i said most of
the study participants were illiterate
so it's not like they could like read
about it in other sources or whatever
yeah so this is where the wrongness
starts to and
yeah and they uh later which i'll get
into in a second they later straight up
prevented
uh people in the study from getting
penicillin there you go that's a crime
against humanity yes yes because once uh
something was available that would treat
it you'd think they would have been like
okay well let's stop the study now
there's no reason to know now now we
have something that you know which is
what they should have done yeah but
that's not what they did unfortunately
so
cha-ching there's money involved
grant money research my funding is uh
yeah
yeah that's what's going on there
yeah so
uh another thing too i think that i
forgot to mention science i mean and
like i said i'm not [ __ ] on science
as a whole because science is whole is
good it's like that's the reason that we
have like most of the good [ __ ] that we
have nowadays but when it goes this way
it when it goes this way but see that's
the thing though and this and i'm gonna
get into this later on too because i
think this is in a way it's kind of like
you yes you have to like maintain
skepticism yes you have to like look
askance at [ __ ] but
you can't across the board i don't trust
scientists i don't trust doctors i don't
do this that and the other thing because
it's kind of like well what are you
gonna trust then because i do kind of
feel like
the reason that we live in the modern
world that we live in with all of the
conveniences and all of the you know all
of the progress that we've made as far
as and i know it some people think that
we haven't but you know what i mean like
you know people nowadays like live much
longer much healthier you know we have
air conditioning and flush toilets and
we have like all this other stuff that
was all
scientists that was all you know people
inventors [ __ ] like that people that did
that so it's just kind of like yes it
does go wrong sometimes yes some people
decide well i'm going to play god and
i'm going to do this and the other thing
but
by and large i think it's a good thing
so you can't [ __ ] on science as a whole
just because
a handful of scientists in this
situation
uh did some really really [ __ ] up [ __ ]
so and i think that it's bad to
and it kind of it kind of uh you know
happened a little bit with this
situation too because i do kind of feel
like over these it wasn't just this but
there was other stuff that you know went
on like systematically ever since the
civil war before that even but you know
obviously a larger proportion of the
black community does not trust medical
doctors because of this because of other
things that happen before that and that
ends up actually kind of like hurting
them in the long run
uh because they don't so
it's it's bad it's a double-edged sword
but like i said you can't it's almost
kind of like it's kind of like [ __ ]
on the internet because it's like you
know oh twitter is a cesspit or whatever
but it's like look at all the good [ __ ]
that the internet does you can't you
can't have it both ways you got to take
the good with the bad
um
you know but i i think it's just really
reductive to just say oh all the
internet is bad or science is bad or
whatever that's dumb
you can't
you're not going to make any progress
otherwise yes you got to keep an eye out
for you know [ __ ] like this happening
but you can't just dismiss the whole
enterprise out of hand because look at
all the good [ __ ] that you'll be
throwing away with it you can't throw
the baby out with the bathwaters what
i'm saying so
so yeah so i did kind of want to go into
that uh which i will in a little while
now another thing that i forgot to
mention was that not only did they tell
these men
that you know yeah we're giving you free
treatment for
your bad blood whatever
uh they also said they were gonna give
them free burial insurance which
sounds a little sinister yeah but well
no but i mean the thing about it though
awful pokey yeah probably running
through the house like a whole herd of
damn buffalos she crazy yeah she was
playing with her toy last night and i
could have sworn i heard a growling
really loud like
and i was just like what the [ __ ] it
woke me up it was kayla's thing trying
to kill it huh trying to kill your toy
yeah you get it pokey
um
free burial insurance but like i said
you have to think this is the 1930s
these are mostly sharecroppers we'll
miss them had wives and families and
most of them had like zero money
and so getting free anything was
probably good because they're like well
you know what happens if you know my
wife dies in childbirth and i don't have
the money to be to for a funeral or
something like that so it's probably
something that they thought along those
lines uh they also when they were at the
institute they gave them like free
transportation to and from they gave
them free food they gave them all this
other stuff so they gave them a lot of
incentives which like i said
considering what their lives were like
it was probably like
well okay you know i can see why people
went along with it because it sounded
good right and you were getting free
[ __ ] you were getting free food and all
this other stuff free medical care
you know free death
well yeah but like i said they didn't
know that did they
like i said i'm not blaming any of them
at all because it's like why like if
somebody came to this you know if
somebody came to you and you were like
broke and had no [ __ ] money and you
need to like feed your family
i didn't even know that they had
syphilis
no they didn't
and they didn't tell them
like i said that's that's another [ __ ]
up thing yeah
that's not legal anymore but it was
legal back then uh you they did blood
tests and they did all this stuff and
they yeah the ones that had syphilis
they didn't tell them they had it i'd
think that maybe some of them this is
not real clear from some of the sources
but i think some of them did know
uh or suspect but the ones that they
tested and like they've most of them i
don't think they told them
they didn't tell them they had it
uh but yeah so they so they did give
them like mine and they also treated
them for like other minor illnesses too
like while they were at the institute so
like i said they felt like oh i'm
getting free food and free medical care
so it probably like whatever yeah as
soon as that penicillin came out man
[ __ ] and they continue
that's what i mean that to me like i'm
not saying that that prior to that that
that was like uh forgivable because it's
not
but the minute that penicillin came out
and they said oh this'll treat syphilis
and they didn't immediately end that
study yeah and say yeah go get go get
treated for that yeah that's when it
became monstrous
right there they didn't tell them to say
look uh whole time you this bad blood
you have the real name for that is
syphilis and that we can now cure it
and [ __ ] we're going to start giving
you this here that's what they should
have done that's exactly what you should
do that's what they said they're dumb as
rocks
and [ __ ] you know what i mean
you you have to [ __ ] tell them this
is what you have all right and we can
now cure it and it's bad and if you
don't treat it then
you're going to go blind or you're going
to you know or something
i can kind of understand not telling
them if there's no cure because now
you're putting this person that's what i
was thinking
duress yeah
they're now worrying about having an
incurable disease
and you're dealing with a person who's
below average iq
why not just give them the best quality
of life as possible tell me you're
taking care of them and you're treating
them and you're watching them for bad
blood and we're gonna do what we can for
you
and you learn as much as you can about
syphilis during that time and when
[ __ ]
penicillin shows up and goes hey this it
responds well to penicillin that's when
you tell them
yeah because they didn't do that that's
telling me that that money was involved
okay that he was involved and they saw
these people as body bags
[ __ ] excess population
and that they weren't where the [ __ ]
anyway so let's just make some money off
of them before they go that's what these
[ __ ] are thinking
okay and yeah there might have been
black people involved in this they're
kind of thinking the same thing too
they're like yeah [ __ ] them all
sharecroppers i'm getting paid
that's
they're in on it if they knew all the
details
yeah they might not have i'm not really
willing to go that far because nobody
really knows yeah but
you know nobody that didn't work for the
public health service
obviously they probably didn't know all
the details
if they did work for the public health
service i don't know if they knew or not
it's possible they did but it's also
possible they did it i'm going to see
how this is going to go
but it's going to come to light and it's
going to be swept underneath the rug
because of the embarrassment that's
what's going to happen here that's not
what happened is that happens okay we'll
see see that's that's what you get for
talking out your ad i'm talking about so
i'm thinking that
other people find out about it and
they're like uh oh [ __ ] they did that
well this looks bad okay we're not gonna
talk about this anymore that's not right
that's not what happens okay
um there actually was a silver lining to
this [ __ ] up thing where you know
uh but yeah that's well that's what i
was thinking it's that and i was
thinking this too when i was reading
about the case i was just kind of like
it it's barely barely forgivable if like
you said there was absolutely no cure
and there was nothing that could be done
about it
um then you could make the argument
still kind of [ __ ] up but you could
still you could make the argument okay
well then maybe not don't tell them
because there's there's nothing you can
do about it anyway yeah but like you
said i mean there were treatments like
mercury and arsenic and stuff they
didn't really do all that much though so
again questionably moral but
uh not too bad but like i said as soon
as penicillin came along
that's when it should have ended but
then it didn't and that's what's [ __ ]
up
uh so the first clinical data uh by the
public health service was published in
1934
and their first major report came out in
1936 now again this was before
penicillin had been discovered as a
treatment for syphilis so at this point
like i said they weren't making any
secret about what the end goal of this
uh study was
um
so other medical professionals read it
uh it wasn't really seen as that big of
a deal i think there were like some
people even back then that were just
kind of like bro that seems a little me
but you know what i mean but in the 30s
before penicillin nobody made that much
of a stink about it
now what ends up happening a little bit
later on so this so the study goes on uh
you know as it was
then world war ii comes along
uh
256 of the infected subjects
registered for the draft
now when you register for the draft
obviously you had to have a full medical
exam
during the course of this medical exam
it was discovered that they had syphilis
and they were told that they had
syphilis because
obviously
um
so uh basically so the armed services
are like yeah they have syphilis so they
should
yeah
so they need to be treated for that
before we can
let them in
uh so what ended up happening then was
that the phs researchers
um
kind of like went to the
you know the recruiting the us army
whatever
and we're like
uh can we not treat them because they're
part of a study so they
intervened
um and said don't draft these people
they're part of a study of syphilis and
we don't want them to be treated for it
because that's kind of the whole point
of the study so they
they deliberately went to the armed
forces
and said don't treat them for it
um even though the men had been told at
this point that they had syphilis and
had to go get treated for it and even
though uh [ __ ] penicillin was
available at this time right at this
point it was yes
uh and because like i said that's what
the armed forces said you have syphilis
you need to go get treated for it go get
some penicillin and then come back
uh but the study people were like no uh
no just leave it which is [ __ ] up
again
uh so one of the directors of the study
his name was raymond uh vonderlair
vonderler i think is how you pronounce
his last name uh this is a quote from
him he says
this is what he told the armed forces he
says this study is of great importance
from a scientific standpoint
it represents one of the last
opportunities which the science of
medicine will have to conduct an
investigation of this kind
uh dr smith who was another doctor on
the study asked that these men be
excluded from the list of draftees
needing treatment in order to make it
possible to continue this study on an
effective basis
so that's they pleaded with the armed
forces and the armed forces said okay
yeah you got that bro so they didn't uh
they didn't treat him
some people were saying that hey you
know this is 30s this is the same time
all that stuff in germany was going on
and yeah eugenics was uh
was a big thing oh that's like way
stronger
is it
that's a different vodka different vodka
that's vodka vodka okay that's
pocketbook that's not the vanilla vodka
no
yeah eugenics is a reality
and a lot of scientists today are are
you genesis they they you know you just
gotta [ __ ] you gotta watch your p's
and q's but
and here's the thing i'm not condemning
them for being eugenicists there is a
certain thing to there's a lot of truth
to eugenics but you also gotta be
ethical okay
human experimentation
you gotta be real careful with that
you can experiment on humans but those
humans have to know exactly what it is
that they're doing
if they don't understand what's going on
well this is actually the study that led
to that yeah uh so that's what i mean
where this didn't get swept under the
rug as soon as it came out there was
like a huge [ __ ] which like i said
i'll get to it
you jump the gun on me i'll do what i
gotta do
i'm bringing culture to this show
[ __ ] the the
i would be involved in a human
experiment a human experiment as long as
i knew everything that was going on but
like i said legally now they have to
tell you right exactly what it's for
exactly what you'll be doing right uh
you know and you have to like sign off
on it is it okay if this happens if that
happens if this happens no difference
between that and being a test pilot or
an astronaut that's what i'm saying and
i honestly
it's and honestly that should have been
duh that should have been like common
sense
obviously you know people do need to you
know participate in drug trials for
example
but and i don't have a problem with that
and some people will do it willingly i
would do it willingly if i was you know
if i had some disease that was [ __ ] up
and they had a drug for it um yeah i
would participate but like i said the
law is now
that they have to tell you exactly what
it is exactly what might happen they
have to tell you everything about it
but see they didn't do that for this and
this but this is what led to that later
on all right
um the informed consent thing uh among
other things but that this was the main
thing that led to that happening because
that was kind of the whole point is they
didn't tell these dudes that they had
the disease and then deliberately
did not treat them for it even after
treatment became available which like i
said is [ __ ] up
um
so later on what ended up happening this
is really [ __ ] up too
um so this dr smith person who we
mentioned before
uh he writes to this other doctor dr uh
vonderlair
and he says okay what happens if just
he's like what happens if somebody who
was a control in the original experiment
like they did not have syphilis
but then uh you know as the years went
by because like i said this went on for
a long time as the years went by they
contracted syphilis later
like when they were registering for the
draft like this was a negative and now
he's a positive so what do we do about
that
so the doctor says and this is quote
so far we are keeping the known positive
patients from getting treatment he said
that outright we're keeping them from
getting treatment quote unquote
is a control case of any value to the
study if he has contracted syphilis like
if he got it later
shall we withhold treatment from the
control case who has developed syphilis
so the other doctor vondelier he says he
writes back he says
such cases have lost their value to the
study there's no reason why these
patients should not be given appropriate
treatment unless you hear from dr austin
deibert who was kind of a higher up dude
who's in direct charge of the study so
at least
people that got syphilis later after the
study started he's like okay well you
can let them go and they can go get
treated however people that had syphilis
from the beginning no we're not giving
them any treatment
uh so again 1947 uh penny penicillin uh
was pretty much the standard therapy for
syphilis and actually quite effective
um and uh the us government at this
point uh you know because of uh
penicillin becoming more widespread they
they had a bunch of public health
programs set up all over the place and
they were trying to uh they were trying
to eradicate syphilis uh you know pretty
much so they set up like all these
different like little treatment centers
everywhere like in big cities and stuff
and they you know it's very easy to
treat just get there and get it and
we'll try to like wipe the [ __ ] out
uh so they had all these campaigns to
get rid of an aerial disease you can
still see like posters and stuff from it
like from back then which were like
really funny honestly like even on
uh mst and stuff like that not so much
on but and some on riff tracks they did
they had all those like uh army shorts
from back in the day like about
different stds and stuff and how to go
and get treated and everything so yeah
so there was like a big public health
push to
you know syphilis and other stds to go
and get treated for it and uh so it was
like a big concerted effort
now uh
eventually these campaigns came to macon
county alabama where this uh where this
study was going on
and um the researchers who were
directing the study uh
legit like stopped the participants from
finding out about it and
you know wouldn't let them go
get treated even though the
the government had set up all these
things to help people get treated
uh you know some of the people i think
in the study did actually go and get
treatment anyway
um
but it wasn't really like enough to
treat it i guess but some of them
actually did try to go get it anyway
now this study went on as i said for 40
years so it didn't actually end until
1972
and it only ended then because
somebody as i said blew the whistle on
it by the time somebody blew the whistle
on it which i'll get into in a little
bit
uh only 74 of the test subjects were
still alive
uh out of the original 399 men those
were the ones that had syphilis at the
beginning of the study
28 had died of syphilis 100 died of
related complications you know things
related to syphilis yeah you got
weakened and something else got you yeah
because yeah like i said this weakened
you yep
uh and this is special
40 of their wives had been infected
because they didn't know that they had
its collateral damage
and 19 of their children were born with
congenital syphilis because they didn't
know they had it yep and they probably
if they had mistresses or went to
prostitute certainly i'm sure they
probably passed it to other people too
without knowing that they had it again
this is why you can't tell like [ __ ]
people that have
transmissible diseases you should really
tell them that [ __ ] so they do not pass
it to other people duh
but yeah there's there's that so like i
said collateral damage which is [ __ ]
up
now uh as i said this study like when it
went on uh in starting in the late 40s
or early 50s i think
some other employees of the public
health service
uh were speaking up and like saying this
is [ __ ] up this needs to be stopped
it's unethical
so there were actually two doctors
actually austin deibert who was one of
the kind of higher up dudes in it and
another guy named albert isgrant and
they came forward and said look this is
immoral um and they're like and it's not
even a really good scientific study
because they pointed out
that and this was in 1955 i think
they pointed out they said look if the
whole point of your study
was to find out what happens when you
don't treat syphilis they're like yeah
you didn't give them penicillin but you
gave them the other like less
effective treatments like mercury and
arsenic and stuff so you did kind of
treat it so you're not even so there's
like the study is pointless because
you're not leaving it untreated so it's
like they're not you're not even doing
what you set out to do
as [ __ ] up as that is and they had 100
years of experience of that anyway yeah
that's what they were treating it for
the past 100 years huh
yeah what did they need data on that for
that's what i mean and and like you said
once they once they had discovered that
penicillin worked on it
i mean there shouldn't have been any
point to the study anymore
they'd be like finding a cure a cure for
aids and say well [ __ ] the cure we're
gonna uh
we're gonna see how [ __ ] die
from aids
it's like there's no point in that
anymore like not like not even from a
like moral standpoint because obviously
that's monstrous like i said but it's
from a practical standpoint you don't
need to do it anymore it's about money
you can treat it now so money you know
it's it's kind of like [ __ ] pointless
that institution was making money off of
it it had been
monetized they didn't want that business
to disappear
so yeah on the explanation so yeah so
these two doctors who like i said one of
them was kind of high up in the study
and they're like look this is [ __ ] up
one you know it's unethical and two it's
not even proving or you know what you
set out to study so it doesn't have any
point to it so that was in the 50s so
like i said people even back then were
saying no this isn't right
there was another guy in 1965
named irwin schatz now he didn't even
work there he was just like a doctor
from chicago and he actually wrote read
an article about the study in a medical
journal and was horrified so he actually
took it upon himself to like write to
the study's authors like what the [ __ ]
are you even doing that's not what he
said but i'm paraphrasing but he's
basically like what the [ __ ] are you
doing that's like super unethical
and i can't believe you're out there
just like [ __ ] flaunting it like you
put but published an article about it
like you're not even making a secret
about what you're doing holy crap and uh
so he wrote to them
and uh apparently one of the study's
authors read it and was just like threw
it in a drawer somewhere and that was
about it
somebody mentioned in the comment
section that during pearl harbor
uh in the 40s
black
uh
black guys in the navy they were could
only be cooks or
janitors
and during the pearl harbor attack one
black guy ran out there everybody was
getting all shot up by kamikazes and
japanese zeros he ran out there and shot
down a japanese zero
and a whole bunch of white guys saw it
happen they [ __ ] cheered him on it
gave him a standing ovation for knocking
that plane down and it was stuff like
that during the war that
really um integrated the services
because racial segregation didn't make
any sense in the service doesn't make
any sense of combat
so there's a lot of frontline guys that
really supported it uh not everybody but
the guys that actually saw the fighting
were like yeah let them fight now there
is something else though
there's two different arguments to that
because i came from an integrated army
there's another argument against
integrating the army at that time how
the hell can you ask these [ __ ] black
dudes
to sacrifice their lives and to fight to
die and kill
for a country
that wouldn't even allow them to vote at
that time
yeah and that's awesome yeah i mean
now some of those guys are coming out of
the
tuskegee institute they were they were
becoming pilots and they were their
argument was that no we want to fight to
prove that we're american citizens and
that we're patriotic and that we deserve
the vote but i can understand like both
arguments yeah i can understand if you
totally didn't want to i'd be like [ __ ]
this volunteer how can you draft a dude
to fight a war
for a country that won't give him a say
he doesn't have representation in the
government
see
so well [ __ ] and until the 1960s they
were like they you know they drank from
different water fountains yeah for
[ __ ] sake i think it was depending on
where they were depending on where it
was and what state it was there's like
why the [ __ ] would you want to fight for
a country that treated you like yeah so
it's like i can totally [ __ ] but then
again you could say well it wasn't all
states so not all black people saw the
united states that way yeah and as i
said some states yeah
were segregated
uh but i think in most states
black people were not allowed to vote in
the national elect election at first and
then they were allowed to vote in the
national election election but their
vote didn't count as much as a white
person i think what was it three three
fifths three fifths no that was all
temporary but world war one world war ii
basically resolved all that now there's
got to be some kind of integration and
then soon after that civil rights act
which they got the right to vote
rights of full civilians
because uh
you go black people just weren't
american civilians they were like
something out of the old testament they
were like captives they were like
kind of like the [ __ ] israelites
inside of egypt they were like captive
foreigners
that was the that was i mean essentially
i mean you have to think it's kind of
[ __ ] up because look at i mean this
[ __ ] kind of blows my mind too um you
know because this is something i can
kind of relate to but
you know i mean women couldn't vote in
the u.s until like the 1920s yeah 1921
was it something like that yeah that
wasn't that long ago my grandma was
alive
so
um you know again not that long ago and
i recently read something the other day
that
i think please correct me if i'm wrong
because i'm i can't remember what it was
women could not have a credit card in
their own name it had to be sorry
until
1974. yeah
i was alive
all right
although that may have been dependent on
what state you were in it probably was
well like i said you you know it's
usually it's goes state by state uh you
know you don't usually have like these
there's a lot of weird [ __ ] i mean you
know if feminism is to give the right
give equal rights to female citizens
then i guess i'm a feminist
you know what i mean yes that's all some
of this new third and fourth wave
feminism nah that's just too hokey it's
just that men you know men and women
should have equal rights
and equal representation under the law
that's what it means and they should be
able to get a job and earn income and
own property that's pretty basic which
like i said we couldn't for a long time
which like i said just in my grandma's
time and even in my lifetime
uh you know the people that are younger
than me even in my lifetime a woman a
married woman could not have a credit
card that just had her own name on it it
had to go through her husband well did
you um did you guys see um [ __ ] man what
was that [ __ ] what was that stephen
king thing delores claiborne or
something like that and uh
she wasn't allowed i think it was
dolores claiborne and she actually
wasn't allowed to like her husband
disappeared like she bumped him off but
he he had it coming um
it wasn't like on purpose she kind of
like pushed him down well but uh yeah
then she tried to like get money and
they were like well your husband's not
here to sign off on this check so you
can't access your money even though her
name was on the account too yeah um but
she couldn't get it right so that was uh
yeah so that was another thing that's
like something you see out of the middle
east yeah if you were married you were
essentially treated as though you were
your husband's property or your
husband's child or you're like a child
yeah is what you were treated well i
didn't have a right to to travel or
leave like you could
yeah you didn't have any rights of your
own yeah that's that's that's pretty
[ __ ] backwards yeah yes it is yeah
yeah speaking as a woman that is very i
don't know i would not like that now i
don't even know how that was justified
or why they even thought that was okay
i mean that was that because our periods
make us crazy i don't know
i don't know i would just think it was
something to do with the religion it was
that it was almost kind of like islam
or something or
maybe they justified it by saying well
literacy
rates in women are not good so therefore
they can't vote and they can't make
these kind of decisions they're like
children i don't really know how you
justify it i didn't live back in those
days
um maybe they treated women
kind of badly so they kind of grew up
half crazy
and therefore they in relation to the
men of the time they did act kind of
crazy because if you're i'd act crazy
too if i got treated like that's what
i'm saying
yeah [ __ ] man can you blame them
well they were locking them up in insane
asylums all the time
yeah for just like random ass [ __ ] it's
like oh man she talked back to me like i
did something she didn't like and she
called me out on it so she's obviously
crazy slammer in the [ __ ] yeah it's
great so it must be that they just uh
were kind of real strict on women and
women would blow up because it's just
inhumane conditions
but the culture at times said well that
[ __ ] must be crazy so we got to lock
her up
so yeah that happened a lot so their
idea of what normal behavior was was
probably pretty [ __ ] strange yeah
that's that's
i mean me and you were gen xers we come
out of a [ __ ] punk rock movement you
know i can listen to john lyon i was
listening to john lyon today i'm amazed
that he was [ __ ]
that he was
uh outrageous in his in 77. there's lots
of
that's the way i would you know well no
one would notice him now nobody would
notice him today no one would know
they'd ask him crazy questions oh my god
he said [ __ ] on tv yeah they were asking
him crazy scandalous it's like i don't
give a [ __ ] what you think of me you
know what i mean and they're like oh oh
yeah you know
but honestly i'm glad that no one gives
a [ __ ] about that stuff anymore in a way
it's like it's in a way it's sad because
it's like oh nothing's shocking anymore
but in a way that's good i think that's
good it's kind of normalized now
some of the weird stuff you see on
tick-tock and some of these kids where
they're growing up although you could
they're under the influence of them
social media we didn't have that when we
were kids and i'm sure that would have
turned me into a monster man me and
steve grabbed her so he's in the he he
grew up with us
if me you and steve had social media
back in trenton high school days we
would have been monsters man i'm so glad
we didn't have social media we would
have done all i don't mind it nowadays i
don't think it's a scourge on humanity
or nothing like that it's a little it's
just like everything else it can be used
for good or evil yeah you know the the
actual platform itself that's not is you
know it's neutral
but it's just i'm glad that i didn't
have it growing up because it's like i
didn't use that [ __ ] well i wouldn't
have wanted like [ __ ] for my teenage
years and stuff like that like haunting
me now right like horrible pictures of
my stupid ass
i'd have been trying to do to do [ __ ] to
make but make me
i'm glad that a lot of [ __ ] that
happened in my teenage years like stayed
back then i don't let anybody do it i've
talked to sophie about it
she's generation younger than us or two
generations younger than us and she says
that you know she's analyzed our
generation and what we watched and we've
talked about
we were
more socially adept when it came to face
to face
well you had to be we didn't have an
option yeah that's all we i wasn't
though but i mean you know in general i
guess we because i didn't like like
talking to people i still don't graphics
could [ __ ] attest to a [ __ ] face
to face i was [ __ ] great face to face
i'd entertain you or i'd get my ass
whipped it i'll just depend i was i was
a risk taker
but
risk yielded reward didn't it grant us
risk or yielded reward back in those
days our social media of the day was
talking [ __ ] that was social media for
us talking [ __ ] talking [ __ ] going up on
stage and doing a live show
or
being in a band or being an entertainer
an actor or then later on a soldier and
a [ __ ] cop anything that was high
risk high adrenaline we liked that [ __ ]
skateboarders we had all kinds of
physical physical stuff
today it doesn't
some of these kids like um like nick
even though nick's a great kid he's a
little bit of a wallflower
yeah you notice that but it might but
that and i see the thing about it though
those little
in a lot of ways i don't want to be one
of those old people that's just kind of
like oh the generation behind me right
yeah because everybody's different um
you know everybody when we were growing
up gen x oh you slackers you don't care
about anything obviously we were right
and they were wrong well yeah i know
that but i'm just saying that like
everybody's different you can't just
like blank it i don't like that whole
like generation oh boomers oh
millennials though this i mean we make
boomer jokes a lot of times
but all boomers aren't the same maria
maria is a boomer yeah and you know i'm
not [ __ ] she knows what we're
talking about though that's what i mean
when i say that and when i like
sometimes like some people have got
upset with me like sometimes when i'm
like oh old people [ __ ] but i don't
mean old people necessarily as in age i
mean old people as like acting like
we're old people i'm old yeah that's
what i mean but i'm just saying i don't
act like an old person hang out with
young people who forget that we're old
yeah because uh when i talk about old
people like disparagingly i'm talking
about old man yells at cloud type yeah
people i'm talking about that type of
thing
there are still there are people older
than us in the scene that are still
[ __ ] competent it's still relevant
[ __ ] um you can age very well you
just have to know the game that you're
in just keep your [ __ ] together how to
play that game and you have to
understand what
how you change over time um and what
your your role will change over time
because
because you're different now you know
what i mean and you got to be like okay
with that like don't
don't try to be a young person no you
can't be young you know
what's up fellow kids don't be that
person okay like don't try to be younger
than you are don't try to be like hip
with the lingo or nothing like that
please don't do that that's like lame we
cannot be
that [ __ ]
hot 21 year old [ __ ] dancing with the
ass hanging out and everybody that's
those days are over yeah i mean if we
tried to do that everyone would just
like laugh at us and justifiably so yeah
right yeah i would laugh at me yeah if
i was doing that just you know what i
mean it's like just don't do that just
don't try to be a young person but just
don't
don't ossify that's all it's just you
don't have to like keep up with every
new [ __ ] trend it's like you know
what i mean but
don't just don't let yourself get like
oh i don't give a [ __ ] anymore i'm not
gonna like keep up with new [ __ ] it's
just kind of like one of the reasons why
and this is like kind of like a small
insignificant thing but it was one of
the reasons why
i was like well when i do my movie
reviews it's like i want to do old [ __ ]
that i like but i also want to do new
[ __ ] because
i don't want to be one of those grumpy
ass like grandpas that's just kind of
like oh there's nothing new and nobody
does any new [ __ ] anymore
like nothing's any good anymore and
because that's not true and it's never
been true and i kind of feel like every
generation has that oh music was so much
better back in my day movies are so much
better they don't make them like that
anymore it's like that's [ __ ] it's
like there's so much good [ __ ] out
nowadays and there's good [ __ ] from back
then and honestly
this is kind of like
in a lot of ways yeah there's a lot of
shitty stuff but there's a lot of shitty
stuff in all timelines so i'm just kind
of like you know at all times so i don't
want to be one of those people that just
focuses on that because there's so much
good [ __ ] and honestly the best thing
about now is that now you have access to
all of it uh you know whereas before in
the 80s
there was a lot of good [ __ ] out there
but it was really really hard to get now
there's good [ __ ] everywhere and it's
really easy to get and that's awesome so
like i said when i'm thinking about it
sometimes it's like an embarrassment of
riches it's like oh my god there's like
so many movies i need to see there's so
many books i need to read there's so
much music i need to listen to and it's
like i can't keep up because there's so
much good [ __ ] coming out yeah there's a
lot of crap coming out too but that
happens all the time so
i don't know i i kind of feel like old
is more an attitude than an age so when
i say old people i'm not necessarily
talking about
old people like you know as an age i'm
talking about like an attitude and it's
that kind of attitude where you just
become ossified set in your ways just
don't
get like that that's all
like i said you don't have to keep up
with new stuff it's like
necessarily but
you got to be aware though yeah i mean
keep up with [ __ ] to an extent and like
i said don't become one of those people
that just dismisses new [ __ ] out of hand
because i don't like this i don't
understand this these kids today blah
blah just don't be like that what me and
jenny do is we create new things amongst
around other people that create new
things like club events and band stuff
and [ __ ] she does posters and then
the shirts and
and the hype and everything and then the
younger people enjoy it and then some
then the youtubes the utes and then
we're kind of the teachers of the
younger people and [ __ ] showing them
like hey do you remember this if you
heard this bad what about this one you
know and then
because you're trying to but they know
some newer ones too that i don't know so
they can be like oh if you like that
maybe you like this new people and i'm
just like oh yeah that's cool it's gotta
be you know it's a tune
it's a two-way thing sure yeah that's
cool i like that yeah and like i said
that's that's why i don't [ __ ] on like
oh the internet oh it's the worst thing
ever what is the worst invention it's
not it's like honestly now you can
access almost anything you can almost
anything
you couldn't do that in the 80s no you
can do anything
think about how hard everything was
i would hear about this movie and i'm
like oh my god that sounds like the best
[ __ ] movie ever and you couldn't find
it and i couldn't find it i couldn't get
it
i could see everything now yeah nowadays
you can just still get any you know any
era you want i can go i could spend all
[ __ ] week watching nothing but silent
movies from the 1920s if i wanted to
easy which that's a great boon to the
[ __ ] that's awesome to all cultures
yeah because all cultures can are easier
to
to maintain and you can pass down to
future generations as long as the power
stays on
i mean like i said i just to me i don't
i don't complain about like the internet
this is like way [ __ ] better i
wouldn't go back no um you know yeah you
appreciated stuff maybe a little bit
more because it was harder to get but i
wouldn't go back then because everything
was a pain in the ass let's be honest i
think everything was a big it was a
smaller world yeah
it was also a more mysterious world but
never look back always move forward yeah
i mean definitely i mean i look back at
early internet with a sense of [ __ ]
like nostalgia
you know kind of if you the channel wang
talks about it the old internet from the
90s
and some of that [ __ ] was pretty [ __ ]
cool
yeah well there was cool [ __ ] in all
areas you don't have to like throw that
away
but you could but the fact that you can
watch
a channel that's all about exploring
that
you couldn't do that back in the 80s
like i said
yeah
the fact that people have nostalgia for
that i was reading an article
yesterday
about how
uh gen zer so like not even millennials
but like the millennials kids
are super into there's a whole
subculture on tick tock
of ones that are super into like 80s
fashion yeah and new wave like yeah it's
super they're super super into it and a
lot of them obviously them or even their
parents sometimes weren't even born then
yeah
but they're watching movies from the 80s
and being like man that that looks
really cool i'm gonna dress like that
some of the new bands that have come up
that's super cool i like that some of
the some of the uh the new bands that's
cut that's that that have come up
in recent times and uh uh that are like
friends of ours and ones that we've seen
have an old 85 like corinne yeah
k-o-r-i-n-e
i believe it's how how you
go go look at the song heaven's servant
and you'll you're back to like
84 dark wave maybe [ __ ] it's
we met those guys they were great and
jenny got a shirt from they were super
nice and uh they would believe that they
were so excited that i bought a shirt
from them i just thought that was so
cute that i [ __ ] i said dude i know
that song he's playing after they got
done he says heaven's servant what song
is that and he exists oh yeah yeah
because where'd you hear that it said i
heard it on a uh on a
youtube channel called new retro wave i
was playing that [ __ ] over and over yeah
because we leave that on that's you
because yeah it's us yeah and and then i
got as soon as that song came out i'm
like hey yeah and then and then like uh
that was down in tampa we saw
and then i got into their whole catalog
and it's just uh i think they're from
seattle maybe
are they from seattle or portland i
can't remember seriously yeah i kind of
felt like they were pacific northwest
they were from up north but they were
having a [ __ ] good time down here and
they were super sweet yeah good guys and
i think they they know uh
starry night in them
yeah they probably do because i think
they've played on a couple bills yeah
good band good band
i would say that that they're that
they're up there with their my other
favorite band for right now for for
young guys starry night in corin
yeah i just i kind of feel like
i don't know it
well it's not new i mean the the 80s
nostalgia
uh because in the 80s if you lived in
the 80s uh
there was a big 50s revival
uh you know you had bands like
particularly the early 80s it was like
that was late 70s and then you had like
stray cats you had like a rockabilly
revival in the early 80s and there was
even kind of like
uh you know grease and all that kind of
stuff and then in the 90s i feel like in
the early 90s there was a throwback to
well well i guess it was late 80s or
early 90s there was a throwback to kind
of like acid rock kind of stuff because
i remember i was in high school
in
88 89 90
and there was a very large subset of
people
that were real into
pink floyd
jefferson airplane
led zeppelin
and they would go around like you know
wearing tie-dye and [ __ ] like that so
there was a big like 60s acid rock
revival in the late 80s early 90s i feel
like you know what i mean so it's not
new that kids nowadays are doing like
80s [ __ ] it's like oh hey i'm raiding
mom's closet
and i'm wearing her [ __ ] triangular
blouses with the big [ __ ] shoulder
pads although i never wore those i hated
[ __ ] children first symphony says
yeah 80s 90s internet was more kind of
like based around like friends and
little communities than it was they
didn't have big platforms so yeah i
remember it yeah yeah you could make
friends on there talking about anything
you know what i mean like i used to be
on like uh
uh uh [ __ ] discussion groups like
[ __ ] um
what was it kalishnikov dot r-e-r-u
i believe it was called it was a it was
a russian discussion group from the
kalashnikov company about aks and they
had dudes that actually worked in the ak
factories and design [ __ ] and we would
sit there and just [ __ ] message all
[ __ ] day
any little details about old aks of all
different kinds and he was [ __ ]
showing pictures of [ __ ] prototype
stuff the dude named tantal he's dead he
died of cancer i i tried to
i found his daughter his daughter
survived him but he had died of cancer
in the second because i went to go check
back up on him too bad
he sent me over the years he sent me
some weird
prototype stuff from the kalishnikov
factory
back right after the [ __ ] fall of the
soviet union and they were still kind of
falling he sent me a [ __ ] part of a
magazine from a [ __ ] nine-millimeter
bison which is a little submachine gun
helical tube magazine
we were trading stuff across countries
gun parts and stuff stuff that would go
through you know just gun parts that
would go through uh customs you know
they weren't guns it was just parts
just it was different time man different
time
and it was hard to share even a
photograph and then i remember then all
of a sudden you could share photographs
and [ __ ] the internet got really cool
then there were like gifs
yeah little bits of video
yes okay and the ferrari first digital
cameras started to appear and they
weren't on phones they were separate
yeah that was the [ __ ] man yeah it was
weird i didn't get one immediately
because they were too expensive yeah
they were [ __ ] after 200 bucks yeah
after a year or two when they came down
to like 100 or 200 i got one yeah and it
wasn't that great but you know what i
mean i think it was 1.2 megapixels yeah
some [ __ ] everybody's like ooh fancy
yeah you know you have a hundred photos
even though it's like [ __ ] terrible
now it's like now your [ __ ] phone can
do like a hundred times better
uh i'm kind of behind on comments so i'm
trying to like answer maria said and i
think she's gone now
but uh
i guess me talking about the case she
says jenny i did this for a living and i
want to tell you that you have done a
[ __ ] great job with it better than
any advanced student i've ever had
present this i wish i could stay oh okay
thank you very much
i was i i liked i liked i liked that
thank you very much
um let's see what somebody said oh tammy
said okay she was reminding me of
dolores claiborne and i
feel bad because i know i knew that it
was something about that but i couldn't
remember because i hadn't seen it a long
time or read it in a long time tammy
says he took her money out of the bank
that she was saving for their daughter
his name was not on the account
oh so that makes it even worse that's
right and that actually because i
remember when i read that the first time
i was like man that's [ __ ] up did that
really happen and i looked it up i'm
like oh my god it did so it's like it
was her account it was their savings
account for their daughter's yeah it was
like a college fund or something like
that
yeah grabs i remember jimmy vostak he
was good he was good on the [ __ ]
trumpet even back in high school he
ended up in the 50s revival band yeah
yeah jamie was great he was always doing
he would do the music for a lot of our
shows
remember
some of the live shows that we did
camp guy says my daughter had a friend
in the fifth or sixth grade that falsely
claimed to be pregnant just for
attention
yeah
i think i'd do a kids bike i don't know
if it was six it might have been junior
high
but
yeah some girls they didn't even know
what that meant they were just kind of
like i'm pregnant i'm pregnant and
nobody's like really okay they didn't
now
[Laughter]
uh camp guy said i was born in one of
the very last years of the designation
baby boomer okay
and then hugo says oh those generation x
people i know we're the worst we're like
honestly i kind of feel like gen x is
like the forgotten generation we're the
best generation which is fine with me
because we don't get [ __ ] on as much
i mean we don't get praised much either
but that's cool
whatever that was like was that the most
gen x thing ever to whatever i don't
know i don't care
we were the best because we were in
between
we were in between the old fuddy duddies
we're the liminal
generation we weren't boomers and we
weren't [ __ ] millennials
we were in between
well yeah and like i said both worlds i
kind of like that the first i don't it
wasn't exactly half but maybe well the
first third or
so somewhere around there of my life
i didn't have the internet i hadn't
conceived of the internet
and then
later we got it right
so yeah so it's almost kind of like we
straddled
both the old world and the new world
gen x was the first internet
was the first internet generation
and they were even the ones even older
than us a little bit
yeah billy idol he was from a band
called gen x he's he's a bit older than
me almost 10 years he's gen x though
and um he had came out with a with an
album called cyberpunk and he predicted
a lot of [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that the internet was
really going to be important and that
he was one of the first people people to
actually surf the web made a whole album
about it it's kind of corny looking back
on it now yeah but when it came out it
was like what the [ __ ] is he talking
about he because he was on a whole
nother level
and then a couple years later i was like
oh this is what he was talking about
yeah does it come across as because i
don't think i've ever heard that album
does it come across like some of those
really cheesy like early internet like
things where they're kind of trying to
teach you how to use the internet no
no uh like the ones that dan bell puts
on his show sometimes no
no most most of the songs didn't have
anything to do with it most of you know
most of the songs you know he had he had
this uh
[ __ ] um yeah he had uh a cover from
uh he had to cover heroin from um velvet
under yellow underground was on it damn
i love that oh i had a bunch of uh had a
song called shangri-la it was kind of a
early rock industrial kind of album
it was real different from the other
billy idol albums and people don't play
a lot of the stuff off of it
he
had spiky
hair in some
videos and [ __ ] he had blonde dreads
and other [ __ ] he looked ridiculous
okay
i kind of feel like white people dreads
was a very electric 90s thing yeah but
it was it was a very hacker's he was
trying to he was trying which was a
terrible movie by the way juliata was
trying to reboot his career because not
really reboot his career
he was trying to come out with a fresh
album from from left field and he was
trying to walk away from the old 80s
look the punk rock looks so
it was
almost kind of proto remember prodigy
yeah
proto that yeah okay
uh but it had rock in there i liked it
uh yeah some of it was kind of like uh
um
a computer-based [ __ ] psychedelic i
don't know what do you call it what
would you call that i have no idea i
haven't heard it so i can't dj dj maniac
could probably
probably explain that album looked
better better than me i kind of it was
hit or miss it wasn't a great album but
it was looking back on it
it's not a bad album it was good it was
good honestly i kind of feel like you
saw the same thing happening sometimes
in the 80s yeah with bands that were
kind of famous in the 60s or the 70s
like kind of prog rock or acid rock kind
of bands and then they would sort of try
to reinvent themselves in the 80s as
like a synth pop
probably the most egregious example
obviously being jefferson airplane
becoming starship yeah uh which was
horrifying yeah okay listen
look what he said mango says cyberpunk
was a great album
then he says i haven't heard it so
cyberpunk is an industrial rock album
and it's musically it's a bit ahead of
its time yeah it was i really loved the
track shangri-la off of it i [ __ ]
loved that one the heroine cover was
good
uh all the b-side stuff shocked the
system was okay but all the [ __ ] that
people don't know
that was i really liked that and uh the
album came with a [ __ ] floppy disk
in it
oh it came with the floppy disk
i still have it i have it
somebody might pay hundreds of dollars
maybe i have the original [ __ ] i have
the original [ __ ] jacket and
everything i just gotta find like right
here you guys can't see but right here i
have like a whole bunch of vinyl and
it's like i could probably sell this for
a lot of man i got like [ __ ] i got
the birthday party
i got like misfits i got all kind of
vinyl over here yeah i don't even have a
record player but this is just like some
good i got bauhaus i got all kind of fun
fun stuff over there and most of it's
never been played yeah
camp guy says uh my parents couldn't
work a computer worth [ __ ] my old man
was lucky to be able to play solitaire
on windows
yeah michael my dad could use a computer
but my grandma was like i don't want to
touch it it'll blow up but she was that
yeah so adam and james that's right bro
adam and change he says he's got cds
never floppy i got the floppy and the cd
it came in a big old [ __ ] thick
like fold out cd case i still have it
it's around here somewhere first
symphony says i'm glad i grew up in the
80s and 90s and look back fondly but
it's nice now with how things are for
sure yeah i'm kind of like at the same
level i mean i was born in 72
so
you know i experienced quite a bit of
the 70s all of the 80s
by the night by the time the 90s came
along i'm like i don't know if i like
this 90s action i'm not i'm not really
into it and um you know especially after
punk kind of went mainstream like grunge
went mainstream i was just kind of like
yeah i'm checking out but um you know
what i mean just
metaphorically uh but maniacs make me
want to hear that album again
i was up in [ __ ] car i would be up in
egypt man and [ __ ] gulf of aqua by
listening to that [ __ ] on my [ __ ]
cd walkman that i had what they call
that [ __ ] disc man
didn't even you if you shook it it
[ __ ] skip but i'd be listening to
that
yeah i remember that yeah
pyramids weren't far away went to cairo
and everything it was just a different
time in my life it was a good time
granthar's hammer said 90s music was the
worst corn limp biscuit spice girls
atlantis hootie adele i agree um and
honestly no i'm not gonna [ __ ] on people
that liked it they had some good but
once after about 1992 maybe 1994 uh and
i was more into i was like into goth
music and [ __ ] there's a lot of good
goth in the 90s there was there was some
good goth in the 90s but i didn't like
it as much because i'm more of like a
death rock new wave kind of person was
doing good in the 90s they were i really
like the shrub but but honestly i will
say that a lot of the 90s music went
more
what what's the word i want to use it
kind of went more
i don't know in a direction i didn't
love
uh also i didn't really like that it
went more into the synth poppy kind of
direction i didn't really like that uh
or more of kind of like a
like a dance music
direction i didn't love that
so
honestly like i said i'm more into like
kind of
you know
more punk kind of stuff i like i like
post punk i like
you know death rock i like more of that
kind of stuff so once stuff started
going in the 90s more 90s direction even
in the goth subculture like i said the
the mainstream music i didn't like that
since
forever so that didn't really matter but
yeah the 90s music blue and i didn't
really like
after and i think i brought this up
before but i didn't really like after
like nirvana got real big and then
grunge got real big and punk got real
big and then you had like the offspring
and all that kind of stuff i was like
not
a fan of that whole
situation i i just didn't really like
that to because to me it seemed like
after you had like marilyn manson you
had all this kind of stuff going
mainstream and then it kind of seemed
like people were just kind of like look
how hardcore i am it was just like this
whole hot topic i just i was not i was
not a fan of that so
so in that sense like the 90s seemed
like a black hole of culture to me
i followed it up until
like the early to mid 90s and then i was
like nah
i thought there were some good 90s bads
there were
it was hit or miss it wasn't so much in
the pop realm though but it was mostly
goth
gotham industrial stuff
front 242 was kicking ass in the 90s dj
maniac says yeah this exactly
alternative rock becoming mainstream put
me off music for a long time yeah same
and just got me into more industrial and
death rocking goth as a result yeah i
went more in the 90s and early 2000s i
deliberately went back to like the
smaller death rock subculture because
actually in the early late 90s to early
2000s there was actually like a small
death rock revival
where you had bands like cinema strange
bloody dead and sexy you had bands like
that that were going back to like like
old like late 70s early 80s kind of
vibe and i liked that a lot better than
the more
processed
dancy [ __ ] that was happening in clubs
at the time which i didn't like
so
there was that 90s front 242 was good
what was it charity for you and then
there was another one [ __ ] another
album looked like tyranny for you kim i
forgot what that was called and then
what chem lab came out they were good
uh skinny puppy was still good in the
90s there was a lot of good 90s stuff
you know i mean switchblade symphony
came out late 90s they were good i liked
them yeah i mean i'm not saying there
wasn't anything i'm just saying that
a lot of that was like not my favorite
and honestly i was
when the when the death rock revival
came along i was like thank [ __ ] god
jesus susie was great
yeah that's true but
you know like i said there was still
good [ __ ] i was still buying stuff in
the 90s but i just i didn't buy as much
as i did in the 80s because it's just i
even kind of felt like peeps like bands
that i liked in the 80s that were still
that were releasing stuff in the 90s
there's stuff i kind of felt like was
going slicker or like more mainstream
and i didn't like it so there was that
kind of stuff bj aniak's laughing says
jared and i are buddies yeah what's up i
liked his album man
dj maniac also said the fact that a
bunch of middle-class dads knew who
metallica was kind of pissed me off yeah
yeah i you know and honestly kind of
after nirvana i don't blame nirvana it
wasn't their fault but
after never mind came out uh in 1991
1991 was that yeah
in 1991 and then everybody was suddenly
into the [ __ ] and it was just kind of
like it was so depressing because now
prior to that like when i was in high
school and stuff like that it's like
you'd be trading disc with your friends
like ooh husker do and sonic youth and
stuff like that and like nobody knew who
that was really it was like a much
smaller especially especially where i
grew up um but now like every [ __ ]
frat bro knew who that was and i was
just kind of like oh this is bumming me
out for those
[Laughter]
for those who don't know dj maniac he's
a dj down in new york city um i didn't
know you were friends with a guy up in
new york up in new york from here
everything's down from me
i'm on the top of the world wherever i
stand that's the north pole top of the
world everything is down for me
yeah i made that [ __ ] up just right
right just right here um maniac i didn't
know that you knew kim lab man tell tell
them i enjoyed i had two of their albums
i enjoyed their albums they had an older
one it was kind of underground i really
liked that one
then the other one
came out after that came out in the 90s
i guess that was around 93 or 94. it was
a real polished album it was almost kind
of like a nine inch nails i like that
one too i forgot the names of both of
them they're around here somewhere
but uh no i like to bump
there we go another thing i liked about
the early 2000s not only was there a
death rock revival there was also that
whole dark cabaret
off shoot of goth i was really into that
too
um because that was see i like i like
music that sounded like old [ __ ]
if you were going too slick or you
sounded like you know some of the synth
pop that came out especially in light of
like vnv nation and uh you know uh and
one and stuff like that i like them
but
a lot of bands kind of came out
afterwards and it's just everything
started sounding the same like
especially in clubs
a lot of goth clubs uh was just pretty
much wall-to-wall
that and i was just kind of like i
couldn't even tell when one song ended
and another one began and i was just
kind of like i'm really not into this
we're so way off topic well obviously
yeah
oh i'm getting way off
i'm just looking down and i'm hoping
we're not leaving people in the dust
well yeah
you probably are okay um yeah so we
gotta get back to this i mean we got to
the point where
uh i mentioned that there was a doctor
in chicago who like i said didn't have
anything to do with the study he just
read about it and then wrote a letter
being like what the [ __ ] are you doing
and they're just like yep
and then they put it in a drawer and
forgot about it uh but the big thing
happened in 1966
there was a dude named peter buxton now
he actually worked for the public health
service he was a uh venereal disease
investigator in san francisco and he had
heard about the uh the study and he was
like you know understandably this is
[ __ ] up
so he sent a letter to the national
director of the division of venereal
diseases and he's like look um this is
really unethical uh you know immoral
should we do something about this
now at this point uh as i said this
started out under the auspices of the
public health service in the interim the
cdc or parts of the cdc had like taken
the study over so he writes to them
and he's like you know we need to stop
this because this is [ __ ] up
now the cdc or at least the part that
was controlling the study uh said no we
need to you know keep going at least
until the study's done which i'm
assuming meant
um we have to wait until all the people
are dead i don't i don't really know
what they meant by like the study being
finished because it had already been
going on for decades at this point
um now they did actually the cdc uh you
know wanted to finish the study and they
got the ama on board and said yeah we
need to finish this because it's you
know for scientific knowledge or
whatever they also got the national
medical association which represented uh
african-american physicians at the time
and they're like yeah we should finish
this because it's you know for science
uh so because peter buxton couldn't get
any traction
writing to them and appealing to them
and saying like hey please stop this
uh he's like okay well i'm just gonna go
to the press then
so in the early 1970s uh he leaked the
story to the press
so it was first published in the
washington star in july of 1972
uh
first actually reported on by gene
heller of the associated press wanted to
give her some credit
uh and it was a massive [ __ ] outrage
uh so it was printed in washington star
first and then the new york times picked
it up
uh and we're like what the [ __ ] is going
on with this [ __ ]
and it was a big [ __ ] deal it was
like front page news all over the place
now uh so enter edward kennedy who is
senator at the time he called
congressional hearings
uh and got peter buxton in and got some
other officials to come in and testify
about it
there was actually so like i said it
wasn't buried there was a massive public
outrage uh when this was published which
is crazy because it's like in the seven
nowadays you published like some
outlandish [ __ ] in the paper and i was
just like man whatever but back then in
the 70s and you see this remember we
were like watching that uh that spy move
from the 70s and he's like his big thing
was like here's this story and i'm gonna
like report it to the press and it's
that's gonna be like the end of it yeah
in the 70s i guess that would happen
because it did happen in this case but
nowadays that wouldn't happen because no
one would care they're all bought up um
well no either no one would care because
it's just kind of like the news cycle
goes so fast or everybody's like oh
that's fake or whatever so it's just
kind of like it's not the same but back
then
uh it wasn't like a massive massive
scandal this was 1972. so uh
very very shortly after it was published
uh edward kennedy brings up they do a
congressional hearings they get
everybody to testify
now uh at this point because there was
such a stink about it uh the public
health service and the cdc
they actually appointed a panel to look
into it so they said check that out what
the [ __ ] going on
uh so the panel looks into it and they
said well uh okay so the men did
actually agree to certain things like in
the experiment like for these treatments
and stuff
um but
because they weren't informed about what
exactly the study was for
um that
ergo the study was medically unjustified
and they said it must be stopped
so
something got done somebody leaked
something depressed and something got
done it was like a big [ __ ] deal
so uh they actually had some
congressional hearings also later in
1973
and the next year 1974 congress actually
passed so like i said some [ __ ] happened
it wasn't just like swept under the rugs
some [ __ ] actually happened that changed
it
1974 they passed to the national
research act
and actually ended up oh okay now i
can't talk anymore because
he's taking my no not ugly
this created a commission which would
study and write regulations governing
studies involving human participants so
like i said prior to this
it was kind of like i guess it wasn't
there wasn't really any law like
governing
what you could do
or it wasn't like really delineated
maybe i don't know
but 1974 they actually did pass this
thing that said okay if you're gonna do
a test that's involving human
participants
one of the things that you have to do so
they established they had um under the
united states uh department of health
and human services they
established a office for human research
protections and that had to oversee
every clinical trial that had to do with
human experimentation so now every
single study has to have informed
consent which is what we're talking
about before uh anybody that's going to
participate in your study has to know
exactly what it's for exactly what it's
going to
entail everything you can't like fool
them about anything
at least you know depending on what the
study's for but you have to tell them
that it's a study and what it what it
exactly they're trying to establish
they actually have to tell you if you
have some kind of condition or they find
something in the course of that they
have to tell you uh and they also have
to tell you when they do tests on you
like they have to give you like an
accurate assessment of what that test
says so that was established in 1974. uh
they also established like an
institutional review board uh comprised
of various like you know doctors
psychologists uh you know people that
were law ethics religion everything that
have to oversee all the [ __ ] and make
sure everything is copacetic uh so there
was that also
1979 they actually published something
called the ethical principles and
guidelines for the protection of human
subjects of research this is uh usually
shorthanded as the belmont report
and this is it's not like it doesn't
have legal standing but it is like
pretty much the framework for
everything going forward in you know
whether it's government or corporations
or anything this is kind of like the you
know framework that they use when
they're doing anything to do with you
know humanity at least in the united
states uh no
united states europe uh you know most
other places
that you know that have this kind of
thing they have this
so um you know this was actually i mean
there had been something in 1947 the
nuremberg code obviously uh that
because of the [ __ ] that the nazis did
after the war and the
trial
yeah they did actually establish some
protocols back then but they were a
little more
nebulous uh this one was a lot more uh
comprehensive so this is kind of like
seen as an update to the nuremberg code
which was established after world war ii
so uh it's basically kind of like
the main things three basic uh
principles being uh respect for persons
as in you have to tell everybody what's
going on and everything
uh it's it says
the individual research subjects should
be treated as autonomous agents
uh and that persons with diminished
autonomy prisoners uh mentally ill
children whoever are entitled to
protection
uh beneficence
meaning that the research can't just be
like
for the [ __ ] of it uh it actually can't
do any intentional harm
it has to maximize possible benefits
uh minimize possible harms both to the
individuals involved and to society at
large so that's another thing
uh justice is the third one attention
needs to be paid to the equitable
distribution within human society of
benefits and burdens of research
involving human subjects in particular
those participants chosen for such
research should not be inequitably
selected from groups unlikely to benefit
from the work
and that was seemed like um a deliberate
thing about the tuskegee study because
it was all black men and
you know we know how that went so
they're basically like well you can't
just take a bunch of people from like a
marginalized community and experiment
them on them
for no
particular reason you know what i mean
so they had that going on as well
so again this uh
belmont report
is pretty much like the basis of
human test subjects like pretty much
everywhere like whatever
federal government state government
universities professional organizations
research institutions everybody kind of
like uses this as a basis
also in 1974 you see a class action
lawsuit
against the perpetrators of this
study brought by the naacp
on behalf of these study participants
and their descendants some of whom as i
said wives and children also got
syphilis as a result
uh so they actually did settle for nine
or ten million dollars uh in 1974 which
is over 50 million dollars in today's
money uh so they gave them that and they
also gave them
uh the ones that survived uh they had
free medical care for life and their
descendants also had free medical care
for life so they and they had free
burial they had all that stuff so they
gave them something at least
1994 uh they had a multi-disciplinary
symposium uh held on this
uh situation
and that was at the university of
virginia and they basically wanted two
things they wanted an apology from the
then president who was bill clinton at
the time
and they wanted to
kind of like talk about how can we
prevent this from happening again they
wanted to like establish some
rules uh to prevent this from happening
again so again uh 1997 bill clinton
actually did come out publicly and
apologize uh for this what he said this
is quote what was done cannot be undone
but we can end the silence we can stop
turning our heads away we can look at
you in the eye and finally say on behalf
of the american people what the united
states government did was shameful and i
am sorry to our african-american
citizens i am sorry that your federal
government orchestrated a study so
clearly racist so that's what he said in
1997
they also established uh actually five
of the eight study survivors were at
that
uh where he said that
and they also did establish uh
a committee
that was like a bioethics community that
was in 1999
and they wanted to specifically look
into how studies like that impacted
underserved communities and how they
could uh do a better job of it going
forward
now uh interestingly
so uh the thing about this is kind of
like
this is kind of like a bummer because
there is like obviously like a real
racist component of this right um one of
the guys that worked on the original
study back in the 30s and this is a
quote from him he says
the rather low intelligence of the negro
population depressed economic conditions
and the common promiscuous sex
relationship relations not only
contribute to the spread of syphilis but
the prevailing indifference with regards
to treatment
which is dumb because
the whole justification for these
[ __ ] in the 30s for it's like
well these people wouldn't have gotten
treatment anyway
but the dumb thing about it is the
second they came out and said hey free
treatment for [ __ ] people are lining up
yeah
so they're like negating their very own
[ __ ] point it's like oh they wouldn't
have gotten treatment anyway it's like
the second you offered them free
treatment that they don't have to but
then they took it right so you're just
like you're [ __ ] shooting yourself in
the dick right there well it might have
been to the people saying that
one person said that and then another
one offered it well it's like the
handful of people that were working on
it i'm just saying there was a
perception
and the the directors of the study at
the time that was kind of how they
justified it's like well they wouldn't
have gotten they wouldn't have sought
treatment for it anyway
well maybe because they didn't have any
money
that's what i'm saying and well
obviously that's what it was because the
second people came and said hey free
treatment it was like okay sign me up
well [ __ ] man if somebody told me i
could have free medical treatment for
[ __ ] i would probably go yeah why do you
think i don't go i'm [ __ ] broke you
know what i mean
if you ask me it was just it was a uh
it was an opportunity for the to make
money
through this research
that that's that's all it was really so
they're going to say whatever they want
to say to justify you know what they're
doing
well and i'm sure it probably made them
feel better yeah and it doesn't really
matter who's you know who's dumb or
promiscuous none of that [ __ ] [ __ ]
matters
you have a disease that's spreading
through mankind
you got to fight that disease off before
it [ __ ] ends up going mainstream
of course the right thing to do is just
go where the disease is and treat it
and [ __ ] that would be the normal
thing that a normal person would right
when penicillin came out
instead of handling it out to stop the
spread of the disease
you know uh they let it spread
and it's just well in this one study and
that one stuff it's weird because like
generally it seemed like the rest of the
use like the armed forces the rest of
the government
yeah we need to stop it so they set up
[ __ ] everywhere but this one particular
study they're like no we're going to
leave these dudes yeah and they're doing
a study
don't treat those telling people treat
all the other people
that study was making money
i mean it must have because it's like
why wouldn't they have stopped it no
yeah they should have stopped it because
it was some kind of honestly like you
said after penicillin came along there
was no point in continuing it they were
trying to justify their existence
and keep the money flowing through that
one study everybody else is getting next
treatment
yeah he's like oh no they're telling the
army no don't treat these ones we want
to watch it we want to watch we wanted
to watch and see what happened which at
that point it's like holy crap like why
there's like no because they're there
there was like no point in it yeah i
mean they had already yeah they had
already put in so many years
like more than a decade at this point so
they're probably like well you know
we're just gonna like continue they're
riding the gravy train they didn't i
guess they didn't even want that gravy
tree they're like man i don't want to
have to like go on another study and
then i gotta go
that's what they're doing yeah it's just
yeah it might have just been like
[ __ ] inertia they were just like well
we're getting paid for this so and they
didn't really care about [ __ ] shut down
that means we can't go to work next week
yeah we gotta go find some other [ __ ]
yeah that's exactly what's going on
that's probably why like i said it might
have been money and inertia too yeah
degree so which is [ __ ] up but
honestly the okay this is what's sad
though
is that it's not just this
but the fact that this case now is like
so high profile or so well-known uh
really has contributed not it's not
entirely the the to blame
but it really has cont contributed to
the lack of trust that the black
community at large generally has with uh
public health or you know medical
[ __ ] at large
so um like i said it it predates this
study obviously because some really
[ __ ] up [ __ ] was going on back in like
civil war and [ __ ] like that because
honestly they were experimenting on
slaves um you know the only reason that
you would give a slave medical treatment
was because oh they can't work anymore
or i read it a couple of places that
honestly the almost the entire field of
gynecology in the united states was
predicated upon
slave women who were unwilling
uh subjects of gynecological uh
experiments and various things going on
they didn't like [ __ ]
submit to that [ __ ] but
you know because they wanted them to
have more babies
so there's that whole thing too
uh just you know breeding programs just
like just it was that kind of [ __ ] just
like the horses and other [ __ ] farm
animals you know
but uh that wasn't that wasn't confined
just to black people white people did
that to each other too just look at the
mormons it was all about selective
breeding and and
uh
you know
farmers in general and farming societies
are about the quality of offspring it
doesn't matter who they are
but uh yeah
yeah it's unwilling when you have like a
captive people
yeah it's like you can do whatever you
want
to so honestly you can't i mean you
can't blame
uh you know the general and not
everybody obviously but generally the
black community have a higher percentage
of distrust in the medical community um
just because not just because of this
although
when this study when the uh when the
revelations about this study came out in
the early 1970s
uh trust in the medical community among
the black community weighed down
and they think that that contributed
significantly not all of it but it
contributed significantly to the
mortality gap between black men and
white men that came
much after that because black men were
much less likely to seek preventative
treatment
uh black men would not go be in clinical
trials and things like that which is bad
because if you don't have a diverse uh
you know population of people that
you're doing these clinical trials on
then you're not necessarily going to get
a good idea of how these drugs or
whatever like interact uh so you're kind
of like hurting your own community in
the long run so just black people though
no i'm just saying the engine that
that's what yeah i mean it wasn't just
this that did i remember i remember
white southerners [ __ ] connected with
my family in mississippi with that same
kind of mentality very distrustful
of and a lot of it had and one thing
they were super distrustful was [ __ ]
psychology and psychologists and it was
because of all the damn what was done
in the 20s and the 30s with
insane asylums
and weird [ __ ] that happened in mk ultra
you know brainwashing type stuff that
was happening there's a lot of [ __ ] we
did we covered mk ultra before so it's
not just it's not just medicine it was
also psychology
he also did a lot of bad [ __ ]
this isn't the only thing to happen no i
know but like i said it it really
becomes a problem though if
because in the aggregate
uh you know the progress that we've made
as far as medical stuff goes as far as
that kind of stuff goes is largely
positive yes there have been some
negative things but if you focus just on
the negatives we're like well we can't
it ends up like hurting it's like biting
you in the ass in the long run yeah keep
your eye out for that kind of [ __ ]
because there is some like nefarious
[ __ ] happening sure but it's not the
majority thing though no it's always
kind of like uh yeah but like i said
it's just trust but verify it's kind of
like the best uh thing to have about it
and i mean you know what i mean it's so
it's just kind of like you can't then i
was saying this earlier like when you're
in the bathroom you can't just like
take a a whole institution like science
no and just say oh well i don't trust
anything about that now that's stupid
because obviously the you know 99
percent
no i'm just saying that it's sad how
that happens though and i understand how
it happens like
there's corruption everywhere sure
but that's what i mean but just because
there's corruption everywhere uh you
know that doesn't mean that you can't
trust anything anymore because if you
don't like what are you even gonna do
now then right because it's just kind of
like honestly
well the problem about it too is i kind
of feel like humans in general we kind
of evolved to focus on negatives
that's just kind of how our brains work
you know and
it's a survival strategy admittedly and
that's why it persists
um obviously you know if you
look okay so let's give an example if
you're a caveman
and you're out doing your caveman [ __ ]
you hear a rustling in the bushes
nine times out of ten
that's not
a lion okay but one time it might be a
lion
so it would behoove you to act as though
it were a lion every time even though
most of the time it's probably not right
so that's kind of how humans evolved
it's better to
err on the side of safety
even though most of the time that's
probably nothing it's just the wind or
it's a mouse or it's some [ __ ] like that
it's a false positive you know
so the reason so the problem is that we
don't live in caveman times anymore
so nowadays
there's so much like noise about
uh you know all this negative [ __ ]
happening and honestly like in the
modern times it's much less likely
obviously you're not going to get eaten
by a lion anymore unless you're really
unlucky
because the modern world is like so very
safe
that most of the time
you don't need to worry about the kind
of [ __ ] that we used to worry about most
of the time it's fine you're fine
everything's fine
but
every now and then you might not be fine
yeah you don't give up your yours you
can't yeah you can't give it up but you
can't
but on the other hand you can't live
your whole life like oh my god a lion's
gonna jump out of the bush any second
because probably it's not
probably it never will happen so you
can't live your entire life
as though you're just like on the edge
of disaster all the time because in the
modern world in the united states
it's probably never going to happen to
you and probably the stress will kill
you of worrying about it faster than
yeah what you're worrying about
so
i kind of feel like our brains are not
haven't caught up with the culture is
the problem and
you know it was a survival strategy
focusing on the negative and i
understand that
but
you can't so like i said you hear one
thing like the tuskegee study which is
[ __ ] up i'm not saying that but you
can't use that one study which was only
like a handful of people
perpetrating it and
you know just
say oh well because of that one thing
that happened i don't trust any medical
doctors i don't trust any size because
obviously
that's not going to do you any good
either nobody's saying that though right
but well i'm just saying that i'm just
like pointing that out well what i
wanted to say was that uh in 1999 they
did a survey
and the survey showed that 80 percent
of african-american men
believed that the men in this study had
been injected with syphilis
and this which did not happen
so this is also why it's more likely
generally uh for
uh black men uh african-american
community to believe in medical
conspiracies but more than white uh
people do
and also uh there's also kind of a large
i mean you don't hear about it as much
anymore because aids is not really a big
thing but in the 80s there was like a
huge thing about oh the government
uh
put aids into the black community like
on purpose so that was kind of like a
really big conspiracy that was going
around too and a lot of people did
believe it because of this they're like
well this happened and like i said a lot
of them did believe that the government
had actually injected people with
syphilis which like i said that didn't
happen these people already had syphilis
all they did and almost it's bad but i'm
just saying they didn't give them
syphilis they already had syphilis it's
just they didn't treat it when they
could have and didn't tell them that
they had it
so
it just got conflated
and i can understand why there's a
mistrust there
and i understand why they kind of feel
like well i'm not going to be treated
well if i go to a doctor i you know i
get that obviously it's anybody would
understand that if you'd been like
[ __ ] burned like that
um
but you can't like i said you can't
throw everything out with it because
that's just gonna end up biting you in
the ass in the end that's all
you just have to look at everything
i don't know you just have to look at
everything like anymore everything is
like way more complex
than it is so and honestly i was
watching another thing too that said
it's kind of shitty too because a lot of
people focus on this one study
uh which was terrible
um
you know and people should focus on it
people should know about it
but it's kind of like
another on the flip side of that it's
very easy to just say oh well
that study happened in the past we can't
do anything about it now when we fixed
it in the sense that we passed laws
where you know just theoretically that
can't happen anymore because we have
laws to prevent it uh so obviously
everything's okay now you know what i
mean and so that kind of keeps you from
focusing on maybe other issues you know
inequity and health care that we could
be focusing on uh you know so it's just
easy to kind of like blame this one
thing but it's a lot more complicated
than that but this was like an actually
interesting topic i got like really i
don't know why i got like really
interested in this i knew like something
about it because i'm you know like i
said i'm really into kind of like dark
history i really like dark medical
history and i kind of knew a little bit
about this but i didn't know a lot about
it so it was like really interesting to
do like a deep dive on it
but uh yeah so
are you really yeah you want your
heartbeat
yeah
all right
were you gonna come back or what yeah
oh okay
you think i'm just gone yeah well i
don't know
i don't know you're you're kind of drunk
so you might have just like wandered off
and forgot what was going on no i
figured maybe i'll make us another japa
getty or something something quick and
easy you better make us a pizza
i mean whatever
lionex warrior says i've been off the
alcohol for months replaced with a diet
coke addiction
the caffeine keeps me awake so these
long streams are great for me i have all
that uh pork tenderloin but it would
take two hours to cook it okay [ __ ] that
so you know i mean i know we have people
from all time zones it's only 7 42 here
yeah so it's still fairly early right so
yeah i'm kind of hungry too i mean we
ate like some
you made some
ramen with like i had spaghetti stuffed
with spaghetti sauce on it for lunch but
that was like a while back right
and i drink some protein drink i'll i
can make something else let's see what's
that what's down there
see what's down there that doesn't take
too long because i don't want to like
eat too yeah i want to eat instantly
almost
hungry you want to like order a pizza or
something
man the money man we got to try to clean
up this [ __ ] this month
i know it's like it sucks because i
really want to go back to like the
japanese restaurant but i was like man
i'm so broke i just can't even yeah
you know it's like we have food in the
house but sometimes i just feel like
i just feel like that was all it all
requires preparation that's what i mean
we don't just other than like pop-tarts
and [ __ ] yeah
canned stuff
it can stuff and i don't necessarily
want that but everything else is frozen
we've been doing good though i feel like
we haven't really talked we haven't
really been eating all that much
actually tacos like yesterday we had
pizza but that was about it and we had
then we had some like we had a bowl of
oatmeal that was about it i could do
tacos you want those
yeah that's fine okay but uh you know
all right we'll go ahead and shut it
down then
you sure yeah go ahead and shut it down
all right tom's telling me to shut it
down so i have to shut it down
all right yeah we've been we've streamed
long enough it's all well almost three
hours well two hours and 48 that's
perfect size minutes i don't want to do
these six hour shows like back in the
past
jenny will do a six hour show especially
when she's drunk she's like i'll let it
ride let it ride well i start having a
good time yeah but at least i well at
least i covered i think i covered
everything that i covered
i mean i'm pretty sure i did like i said
i phd tell you that you were covering it
great
that makes me feel better because
sometimes i worry and like i said a lot
of times the next day i'll wake up and
be like oh [ __ ] i forgot to mention this
that's the other thing and that like
really bums me out but okay i think i
covered everything that i wanted to
cover which is good because like i said
i got really interested in this so i
read a lot about it but uh but yeah okay
so we're going to
shut it down we'll see you guys friday
because tom says shut it down yeah so uh
yeah we'll be back on friday evening for
our side track show where tom will be
able to talk about anything but so i
mean he doesn't he does that anyway but
you know what i mean although sending us
money thank you very much who said on
this money who stopped propaganda says
25 bucks thank you very much really okay
well why am i behind i don't know oh
okay there it is it just popped up thank
you very much stop prop have pizza on me
oh thank you very much that's very very
nice of you uh yeah so
we will see you guys on friday night for
our side track show we'll have some
drinks talk about some [ __ ] like we
usually do so it should be fun so it's
nice hanging out with you guys yep and
uh we will see you guys on friday
evening
the stream held out all night
it did yeah no i'm impressed
i was like worried about it the whole
time but i was just kind of like oh ah
it's still good all right yeah i don't
know why it's weird all right so we will
see you guys on friday
good night